[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome
around what is going on
chillin chillin chillin how the levels
is goin on what's going on hustler
motivate all that good stuff massa
wrecked up in there i can't do the name
like saul
i see you got the super chats going so
we don't respect that
he's so sorry he missed the mass effect
of a yeah it was lit
it was lit shout out again
last iraq with the five dollar canadian
i'm sorry carl but bill was spitting
bars as much as i love every two
everyone is the goat with the
storyteller
legendary dishes will fix the clunky
control bills was spitting bars we
cannot
acknowledge that not not acknowledge the
boss he was spitting with back and fat
that was fire you know doubt
i don't know about to go with
storytelling but it always comes down to
world building versus character
development and narrative story so it's
your preference but i will say this
legendary edition i'm looking forward to
it could it it will probably get rid of
the issues
all the issues most of the issues that i
have but anyway what's up man
uh no vancilla what's going on y'all
spider
shawn jaggers okay what's going on
you know what i'm saying the mass whole
1970 said wow
kick reaper what's going on you know say
arcade 4247
what's up what's going on y'all see
y'all out here
how do you say that dave addict what's
what's the it's a dragon ball z how do
you say it
which one peak on future they'd be
saying i'll be cut down to be crowning
me so i would say wrong
they said it's not peak on fusions but
i'm trying to figure like my my power
keeps uh i
it's greening like really hard outside
tyrone israel what's going on yes happy
birthday
game plato was going on
salute you already know all right pycon
oh it's pycon thank you you could tell
i'm not an anime dude right
i don't know any of that because every
time i say his name
cat daddy and they they be clowning
pycon
got it got it i mean able
mass effect three gave us the best
evidence look masterfully could have
been a goat
but we all know about that ending you
know i'm saying that is what pissed
everybody off that's the victory it's
fire there's no doubt about it anyway um
yeah we're gonna get chase money up in
here real quick and uh the rest of the
lords you already
know you know what i'm saying so i'll
see y'all in a minute
you know he said nobody said he's
standing for the lady yeah matrescu
mother miranda and ethan went
[Laughter]
no doubt so we'll see y'all let me get
chase up in here
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh i
guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coach
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on the bl dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tiller uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
but i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back me with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal look i guess you could say
that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boil you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger that's
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for attic if i can
imagine this cooler give you some advice
and invite your girl to your squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny worth the cognito
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it and
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
all right and we are live
hear you hear ye happy's mother day and
all that good stuff to the matriarchs
out there
before we start solving we want to jump
right in because i think we got some uh
super chats we need to address all right
okay so first shout out to my boy mass
iraq to have to say
even though cog read them out loud
already so thank you thank you everyone
uh shout out to massa right smitty smith
with the five dollar super chat shout
out to all the mothers on this mother's
day
lord knows they held us down absolutely
and also salute to the lords the book of
ex already he got the [ __ ] of x popping
out here
you already know so let's get it going
welcome to the iron lords podcast and
also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 208 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got resident evil village
more fps boost titles and a ps5 redesign
to discuss
so we're going to get right into it i
want to introduce a lord whose unique
fashion
fusion of hardcore gameplay mixed with
hilarious comedy
easily makes him one of the og's within
the youtube gaming space
introducing the creating host of the x
chase money youtube channel and the host
of the gmg
podcast the grown man who yells at video
games
low-key underrated music producer with
by far
the best costumes on live stream
live from that black and yellow berg
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
mommy lord chase money how we doing sir
bruh
i'm good yo you all of that
hold up i gotta take notes on this right
well every time i get to a podcast
people like him
introduce yourself i i have no idea hi
everybody i don't really have all of
that
you just gave me the whole roll out
what's up everybody thanks for watching
for making this happen man he's been
trying to
make this happen for a long time so i
got to give to my bro addict
but uh first of all how you been doing
man what you've been playing what's
going on with you
i'm chilling uh we talk a little bit
before the show i'm playing
obviously resident evil finally cracked
open fraternal
uh and then yakuza like a dragon that
was the big well mlb the show
that's like that's like every year
excuse me sir how are you consuming
how am i consuming it yeah what platform
you've had
ps5 oh
so all right so how did it feel when you
spend that 70 bucks oh my god here we go
oh we okay we're doing this
he's a little concerned
i mean i would gladly trade the 70
dollar payoff
because the xbox dudes you ain't had a
baseball game
you know what i say i say thank you so
much because you know um
my playstation was sitting there and
then i said you know because i don't
really play baseball like that
so i was like oh it's coming out again
and they gonna get that but then when i
found out xbox was getting it
i was gonna be real petty and just go
buy it right and then
it came out to game pass and feel
dominance maximus
that's how i was consuming it but i was
just curious about how you was consuming
it
but i see that you stayed loyal to your
platform so that's great my my platform
you know what i really hope i really
hope right there i really had hope that
you was gonna say no i'll play i played
it on gameplay
[Laughter]
on the serious side i feel so bad for
the new xbox players
y'all they probably a lot of them
probably like probably a couple weeks to
a couple months
catching up because i'm telling you on
the streams when you see xbox players
you can always tell because a lot of
them is new
yeah not this one not this one
well you got you got streamers that's
like i'm about to get a xbox to turn off
cosplay
they've been working yeah yeah because
the playstation dudes are serious yeah
yeah yeah they've been doing it for a
minute
it only takes a couple weeks the couple
weeks couple months people be caught up
you know how i'm playing i'm playing um
you know the easiest
i'm playing on like the easiest pitching
um and i know it's
a poster
the one i was used to from before
yeah i didn't move the analog man chase
knows these names by heart
that's he's a streamer he does that
a lot and he does that so yo what's
funny uh chase i was watching your
eternal stream
yeah you came up to one of the uh one of
the red little podiums that you laid
down on
it chase like his chat's telling him no
he
starts walking away he's like you know
what if if i if you if i wasn't here i'm
i'ma do it act like you guys ain't here
you know cause they guide you the whole
time i'm like let me do something that i
would do if y'all wasn't here
no doubt they ended up not doing it
real quick let's couple more super chat
fluid solve let's get those there we get
y'all intros it
sure give me a moment some fun ones copy
paste this last one
um we got funds with the five dollars
let's go
the brothers see you soon fonz i'll be
on that game talks live right after i
open yo
no doubt no doubt that we got flame five
dollar super chat morning lords just
wanted to apologize for being
disrespectful the last few streams
but at least i know what octo means
attic catch it up girl
you catch it then we got
i'm here to hear king bring the smoke
about that ps5 redesign
i got you boy then we got lady infamous
with the five dollar super chat the lord
brought greatness this morning with x
chase money no doubt yes in the realm
salute wrong women gaming you already
know of course there we go
so petty so petty with the five dollar
super chat just in case you missed it
yesterday hope said andromeda was the
second
best battle at the jitter petty i had to
get him i had to get him
don't don't let him get done don't get
it twisted that that was premeditated
guys you had the inside baseball you
knew what i was going to do
i had a feeling i was like i got
something in the works
he was really just that whole goal
anyway so we already got chase buddy in
the realm you know what i'm saying we
got the four horsemen
of gaming those original lords of the
realm here at the round table
my co-host with the cool most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of his own world and the heart of
the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man
i'm tired because i i ended up staying
up till like 5 30 playing
um playing cheese
you know when you see regular oh
[Laughter]
i like you
last night i played probably another two
three hours of
resident evil still not really too too
far into the game
because i've decided to put that on hold
until i beat yakuza so
i'll i'll get to it like sometime next
year because it feels like this game is
going to be long yeah yeah cruise is a
long game
y'all because it seems a pretty solid
game finally caught up on destiny
not now i can put that game down for
like a total of two days for about two
days
it's been a good it's been a good week
of gaming man it's been a good week
again i'm exhausted so it definitely has
been a good week
give a shout out to where you were last
night where was i last night he was on
the shop
podcast i was asleep on the shot podcast
no
i was on the shot part no i i'm asleep
now man i'm tired
have you not been paying attention okay
man
somebody get that man a red bull yeah i
i can't i can't drink that stuff
actually thank you
okay so he's doing blaming them yeah i
was on blame shows it was a great show
uh definitely go check that out no doubt
no doubt
so that has been pretty much it and of
course we got our most technical gaming
lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patient of the iron
bank
my mass effect debate brother lord
sovereign how are we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic excellent yeah shout
out to everybody who came out yesterday
that was
hilarious that was hilarious that that
was good fun
i hope to be doing more of that in the
future because that's what more they
want
they want more they they you know
i didn't watch it i didn't watch it
because i i didn't want you like
skywars i didn't i mean
that's an auto l for a king
and when you actually get a chance to
play it i watch your tune you act like i
ain't played it
actually like you didn't play it on your
switch get busy anyway
i played a little bit of re five so just
the beginning so i have a little bit to
say about that when we get to it
um i actually have an mlb the show story
chase
i i moved i'm a long time playstation a
hardcore but i moved over to xbox
um i he bought it i had a probably i
bought it too
fast i had i had a perfecto going with
um with whatchamacallit uh what the hell
is
his name gary cole gary cole i had a
perfecto with
two hours left in the ninth oh fro
do you know i i forget that they auto
they auto overshift now
oh yeah so the dude
down down the line on the opposite side
nobody was there
yep no and then i almost wound up giving
up the game because then the game starts
to cheat
this i'm on all-star difficulty so the
game starts to cheat and all of a sudden
i was up 3-0 i'm up
3-2 with two runners on base now you can
lose
three consecutive errors and i'm just
like oh nah
man the game was doing it the game was
doing it and then gary might as well be
speaking another language to me right
okay
your defensive settings is do you have
it on button accuracy where you got
landed in the green
yes and you got errors that's just
dropping the ball
he was dropping the ball yeah no it was
it was stuff that wasn't me like i'd get
to the ball
and the game would auto be like no you
missed it no it wasn't throwing errors
cpu they know everything yeah you cannot
steal
the whole game yeah you push l2
they know
they know everything i can't wait to
talk to sports games with you man
yeah i like this i like somebody that
can talk supposedly because
addie said i don't know what the hell i
don't know what you're talking about
dude sir that's been it that's it
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet
of xbox king of the statues demands
nothing that's the premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how we doing sir
you know we doing fantastic first of all
i got the shipment and you see mario
don't kill zelda
you know i didn't see that what's going
on
let's let's validate that that's the
skyward sword zelda
oh no no no that's the last mass zelda
whatever he standed trying to outfit
over him though
oh yeah because he did his thing
he gave them the canelo special broke
his eye socket
well thanos is upstairs i gotta bring
thanos downstairs as you can see those
are two dog phoenix eggs in the box
um watch the kos that kos is up with
green goblin
um the next kos i will bring you is
gonna be black bolt
and then we're gonna go right over here
to um what you call a scarlet witch
so we can go into the history of the
scholar which i can actually know
why she turned into the scarlet witch at
the end of the one division
yeah i i have to i have to give my hat
off to you king because if it's not in
the movies
i don't know i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you what they're trying
to do in the movies and in correlation
to the comic books
because they try to keep the characters
accurate to the books and i and i really
respect that and i love that
i think they're doing it in a way that
can uh we can digest it
but um yesterday last night let's get
into this combat talk bro
real quick all right so we have canelo
versus bj saunders and i know a lot of
people
don't know bj sanders
he's been undefeated for a decade and
you know um because bj really wasn't
fighting the competition
that uh us americans was fighting so he
was over there doing his thing
and he came over here he thought with
the back of the tyson fury which
i think is uh overblown bum um was gonna
boost him
to where he had to be so canelo did what
i said if anybody was watching my
twitter yesterday i told you knife
around tko
and the reason why i said knife on tko
because i turned to one of my wives and
i told her i said listen check it out
this is what's going to happen he's
going to start working his body
and he's going to either beat him to the
body or he's going to dip into a shot a
frown came
at the end of the eighth round came yeah
he was going to the body
bj dipped into the shot broke his eye
socket
went to the corner he finished eighth
round knife ronnie couldn't come out
that's a knife around tko so if you bet
that money like i said
you made a grip and the line on that was
i think it was a thousand to two so if
you bet a thousand or two on a tko
actual tko on that round you was your
money's right right now so listen to me
when i talk this boxing stuff
the reason why and somebody was on my
line saying yesterday
canelo is oh the greatest who can beat
him canelo is a smart businessman
respect his choices on how you uh how
you fight sovereign knows
it's not how you fight it's who you
fight so who you don't want to smoke
with
oh charlo oh yeah the mount charlo but
what he's going to do he's going to
fight after he beats caleb plant he's
going to fight errol spence
at uh uh what's him calling him space
yeah no spins he's too big for spence
it's gonna be a good fight
but it'll go a distance spencer's not
gonna beat him
oh he's too big for him no he's too big
for him
his size does matter in boxing
especially in how you fight
himself so he's too big for him no tell
him to fight charlo charlo knocks them
out in five rounds
period but dudes don't want to hear that
because that's their fan they fancy
family favor
i was
resident evil 7 wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait seven
seven seven yeah seven
oh seven seven seven okay i'm not buying
eight let me tell you why
first i didn't finish seven so i'm
finishing seven i think we know why
you're not playing anyway
no no you bought that i brought i've
been brought seven remember
on playstation for the vr okay and i was
playing in the playstation then when it
came to xbox i brought it in
because it was you know better
resolution and all that other stuff
that's right yeah and i stopped in the
same spot so i'm playing it now
and i really love the hillbilly stuff
it's scary as hell to me right
absolutely nuts but the reason why i
didn't buy eight
because i realized i didn't finish
resident evil remake two
and i purchased resident evil 3 remake
and didn't even open that
they said seven is on game pass the
whole chat going crazy oh yeah but it's
not from
uh
see y'all guys know if you go back and
listen to the streams
i told y'all after i purchased it phil
dominance maximus was really expensive
put it in game pass and i was
literally upset yeah cause you was like
damn
i said this is it so i didn't even open
resident evil 3
and i got to finish that so i'm like
damn i'm gonna buy another resident evil
game and it doesn't make no sense guys
if you're gonna buy a game
and then put it on the shelf and don't
touch it and then by the time you do
touch it it's like ten dollars someplace
absolutely so don't don't do it unless
you're gonna play it and like
everybody's ever give respect to
everybody that's actually playing it
but i wouldn't get around to playing it
so i was just playing that i was playing
um
outriders making my second build i
finished up my stuff in destiny getting
ready for tuesday
shout out to the last word y'all guys
were going in y'all
lots of crazy um and i didn't get a
chance to watch out guys yesterday
because i was you know
in my bag but yes i'm ready for chase
today
i was watching this stuff and this stuff
was really nice you already know and of
course we got the gaming ninja himself
the [ __ ] no beat low incognito spreading
that really to the
of the ilp now telling you what you want
to hear what you need to
hear shout out to that master effect
debate yo it was super lit man
soft had his score you know saying law
my man on ainsley bowden agitated stove
the legendary bill
still well you know what i'm saying yeah
it would have yeah i would have loved to
have if y'all had acg
ac because the ac because acd would have
been the attack dog at the end
[Music]
he wanted to put that mass effect too in
that massive fight
the poll says if for those who watch the
debate
yeah you're not turning anyone with that
debate though
if
what was the premise of the debate all
right so basically which is the better
mass effect game out of the trilogy mass
effect one or two so
which one he's a trilogy but he only
counts yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know three is
it's fire but everybody universally
feels
for the most part that the ending is
what did it drop the ball
so did it come down to one do you like
the world building you know what i'm
saying or two do you like the character
development suicide and that kind of
stuff
and it was it was contentious man by
shout out to the tv man ty got travis
slobo red down thought in the clutch
big shout out yeah i gotta give a shout
out to slo-mo because slo-mo
he put in the super chat here i'll read
a little bit later but slo-mo bro
encyclopedia break it's like knowledge
of mass effect bro he's my secret weapon
i knew anytime anybody was out of pocket
with any of their law
man was in there slow was in there
but yo you know what's funny though when
you're arguing something
that you love you you love both of them
but you love one more
and you're looking for points to argue
yeah because it was funny when i said
that
when i said that that all of mass effect
2 was contrived yeah
i thought i was like damn man that's
harsh i don't think that
was something points yeah we just go
hard
look man it was super fun check out
again shout out the last word like yo
my boy d said super fun we had my boy my
african brother equation man he was
super lit man love his journey
how he made it in the stream and yo he
put it he put a lot of work out here so
check that out
catch up with this new destiny season
other than that um
no shout out to square enix and people
can fly
because y'all did the restoration yeah i
brought my character back and i was
stuck at a title screen
and couldn't log in y'all the worse and
i had to troubleshoot
my own problem and millions of other
people's own problem who couldn't fix it
so yo if you got that problem your
character got restored and you still
can't play
clear your cash which is turn your your
console off wait for five minutes and
uninstall reinstall and then it'll let
you get back into the damn game
so now i'm finally fixing it if it would
have been me mm-hmm
there would the uninstall part would
have happened
about it let me give a shout out to cog
for one week
you are right when it comes to what they
do and the little outriders dudes who
got their joint
um if they made y'all naked right
this is your constellation prize for the
naked dudes
they restored your character now if your
character
didn't do anything and he was naked on
his like his first mission he was like
what the hell is this
all right they restored him exactly how
he was with nothing
for nothing guys right for those people
like myself who was never naked and
played the game
i'm not gonna lie to you every day since
this restart what happened
i've got every time i log in no
i get at least seven to ten
legendaries for no reason no real
[Music]
get back into y'all cause i like a
dragon like being chased was talking
offline oh man
i'm on like chapter 10 11 i got this new
cat
my party oh son it's fire i can't wait
there's a lot of joy going on
and um yeah so that's what pretty much
it let's get the super chats that we get
into the business also
bet hold on one second uh
let me see let me see let me see we got
free r kelly
with the five dollar super chat and
george
that's what we said that's what we said
enjoying village i'm like god station
five y'all playing it on game fast oh
wait
oh no no no that's a waste station five
shout out
then we got suicide kings the two
thousand chat lord cox intros are fired
no doubt of course they are so then we
got slo-mo with the five dollar super
chat
what's this in my coffee oh victory
mass effect two trading team mass effect
one like the new york jets
easy work when their points were more
inaccurate than the makeover
oh [ __ ] are you going in like i said now
we we
everything was beautiful until hogue
said andromeda yeah
yo yo you got to see what i did though
i got home even like how you gonna pull
responsibility
to to be honest with you like that's
like equivalent to being in a final
fantasy debate and you say 13 is your
favorite or favorite
like i think if someone tried to
if someone tried to like put me in that
kill box that's what you did you put
them in the kill box
i lied i was like i don't even know i've
never even played a drama
cutting part is you got to see how his
team try to get away from
you know how you've been hey reading a
magazine
he was like like yo he not on our team
saying this
i was there for you hulk i was there
absolutely he's good he's good
about it then we got a flame two dollar
super chat
show of hands who attended titanfall 2's
weekend oh i did yeah
i played so much of that game i didn't
need to go back to it
what else we got then we got dequan
buying them five dollars would be chat
he didn't say tyson fury was an
overrated bum did he please tell me i
imagined that
oh okay here we go
a tyson fury fan a fan of a druggie okay
oh
yeah i'm ashamed i'm so what somebody
else did y'all to be like oh he was a
crackhead so so what i said bye
[Laughter]
moving on then we got
beater with the five dollars to be chat
hyped at forza horizon is going to my
family's homeland
mexico i just know damn well that they
ain't going to our hometown of juarez
that's great okay that ain't happening
[Music]
finished uh village epic
wow that's what's up amazing village no
doubt
um then we have video games [ __ ] sunday
is the lawyer
shout out to iop and all the moms king
would you rather game exclusively on
playstation or exclusively on a
westinghouse tv
okay so first i see you going for the
juggler second again
you was leaving the gym as i was coming
into the gym
what was that i think that was on
thursday i i got a late day
so god bless saw him neal but i didn't
get a chance to shout uh talk to you
um weston house or playstation
tough decision to see but i get to play
everything
on the westin house oh my i'm done with
you no i'm just
because that's that's kind of hard and
then you're telling me to be like one of
these frauds that miss out on games from
other systems
so i said exclusively yeah i i think
i i gotta
but i can't miss out on playstation xbox
and nintendo and then if
something else no no sorry what's the
house it is
let me throw one at you would you rather
that mark said yeah you could play on
everything okay okay well
weston house sir house it is
chase it's because it's because you know
i
value my tv style so you know you got to
be clarity and all this other great
stuff
no but i value video games diversity in
video games over just you know gaming on
tv so
no doubt no doubt moving on so we got we
got oh we got we got neo games [ __ ]
again two dollar super chat go fund me
the kickstart for those bad emmy two
takes
jesus um and in the words of the great
bill stillwell go play your dating son
bill's at bars bill has some moments bro
love you neil love you we got peter once
again five dollar super chat
happy mother's day to all the milfs out
there especially my wife
we aren't who we are without
[Music]
yeah yeah it was spooky there for a
minute attic was in the chat like oh i
don't know what's going on
and then and then whole cat the you know
paul had the whole gay drama
then we have ksante five dollars salute
to the lords appreciate that me too
crowning as they go i don't know where
this crowning comes from like i don't
know what you're talking about
you all should be careful sunday is
slowly becoming the day of smoke
i think it's been the day of smoke for
quite some time already
and spartan ghost with the five pound
super chat mass effect two is king
ps5 is a pile of nuts and bolts held
together by
five dollars duct tape and cracking
jesus
all right so better ask elon musk for
the ssd expansion yes we are caught up
so look you want to do i got scribe you
want to do patreon then before you
chase cool uh so first off
we have the winner of
our mad mass effect legendary edition
we had a giveaway for that obviously the
the gleam.io giveaway
um and once again shout out to to lord
pete lois now though for sifting through
all the bs
getting the frauds up out of the pounds
trying to win
so the winner of our mass effect
legendary
edition giveaway is
exciting let's go big bad mo aka
also the winner of our xbox series x
giveaway so i'm assuming you want
a nice crispy copy of that for your new
xbox series x sir
i will get at you in the dms on release
day because
i can't gift it to you before that
because you know
microsoft microsoft
and then really quickly we're going to
get to our patreon and youtube
subscribers and say thank you as we do
every single month for your support we
appreciate it every month we grow a
little bit more and it's all thanks to
you so we appreciate it
so the winner of our ten dollar
gift card giveaway is
what we got michael owen owen
okay okay i don't know what that was
alright i see you all right let's get
into this 20
gift card giveaway the winner of our
twenty dollar
gift card giveaway
andy crawley crawley
i know that's real that's free that's
not we not
um let's get into this teespring
giveaway real quick the winner of our
spring giveaway
gerald mack the mac mac
oh the mac just finished getting a bunch
of stuff so you're getting some more
that's what's up no doubt i will get at
you guys if i have your information in
dms if not
uh i'll try to find you because it's
difficult but i'll try
no doubt no doubt so look yo whose sound
is that that's how the heck you in the
back
anyway look man y'all know what it is
man it is that scribe of the month time
that lords of gaming.net
we're blessed to have these tremendous
riders all in the realm that inspire us
to do their thing
first off shout out the entire team
because every month man it is
competitive
dudes are putting in that work you know
what i'm saying a lot of great articles
opinion pieces
walkthroughs all that good stuff so
salute to the team
but you know we got to give it up with
that i
dizzy scribe of the month at
lawsongaming.net a person that we want
to celebrate that went above and beyond
in the month of april
exceptional month he's been killing it
with the content he's been killing it
with our new series
the lord's minute he had one with attic
yeah one with myself
talking about playstation talking about
what's going on with the state of these
games
and breaking news too he broke some
great news stories man
yo this kid is a beast so the winner
of the i dizzy log net scribe of the
month for april is
none other than lord macho aka hector
remix put your damn hands together
put your hands together what's going
on here's the speech real quick bro no
thank you guys so much man uh lords
everybody thank you guess
what's going on guys it's been it's been
a minute it's been a long month been a
long week but
thank you so much for the honor and for
the award honestly it means the world to
me
in this sort of limelight and uh again
just
really gearing towards getting like a
really great group of writers and just
an awesome site in general um super
proud to be part of all of this
and uh man just have a great show i'm
gonna better be tuning in i was gonna
play resident evil
but now let me grind and final fantasy
14 listen to the show because it's gonna
be a good
yo one killing it i saw you also shout
out to asia george
i see you making your podcast shout out
to your partner so what's your part tell
the people about the podcast you got
it's a good playstation podcast you was
it all
the book of jt talk about talk about it
yes yes so it's me the book of jt other
known as jay or
seoul of in lords of gaming and also
walt lando from level one gaming is
right over there
and uh we just host the dual shotgun
sense podcast the playstation podcast
talk about the latest and greatest
sometimes it's not the greatest stuff um
and then every thursday or friday or so
we kind of like break it up but
i'm glad that you actually mentioned
that because we do have a special guest
coming oh we got a plug
whoo it's a special guest oh
you gotta tune in that's the twitters
macho or
um follow solar book of jt on twitter or
at walt lando
yeah man it's gonna be good stuff on
thursday so definitely tune in thursday
what time in a good channel come on man
we gotta work with this plugin baby
[Laughter]
yeah you're right you're right uh yes so
it's um it's 10 30 a.m
eastern standard time and then it's on
the dual shocking sense podcast
twitter as well as the um as a youtube
page uh
yeah follow me on twitter apple macho
and then i'll show that all out
no doubt man continue the good work
brother always a pleasure once these
conventions come back you already know
how we play we're gonna be back in the
building
absolutely i'm ready to run on the mic
with king again we're gonna do it all
over again
[Laughter]
fantastic job bro see you guys quick
quick
quick funny story on the lord's minute
this morning april and i were recording
and my wife got stuck in the middle the
door got stuck
and i had to get up in the middle of it
to go try to open the door
april was talking to me and she was like
hello
so sorry josh you're gonna have to edit
that
look man we got like we got the business
out we got poor chase here waiting he's
like damn his longest intro
what type of podcast is
so look now that we got all the business
out the way all the stuff all the
festivities man we got to start
focusing on lord chase money his video
game
system history his journey into content
creation and of course what led him
to the creation of the chase money x one
and two youtube channel
so lord chase money let's start from the
very beginning what was some of the
first video games you had
and what got you into gaming you mean
like
very beginning very beginning bro and
you know how like
you do stuff and you you've been doing
it so long you don't remember
not it's it's been that long i think my
sister said she taught me how to play
when i was like
three so like we talking
are we talking and yes okay um
we talking again sega channel i'm sure
i'm sure some of y'all old enough to
remember
wow sega channel um
so pretty much so i had i had a
nes super nes sega
and then i never had a ps1 unfortunately
i had an n64 at n64
and then i ended up with the ps2 um
i got a og xbox real late i had one of
those and then i had
everything after that except the
original wii
which was a great system but i had no
money
you know i mean i didn't get it it's
real tough i mean
yeah so obviously you know like the the
first game
that i can remember is the first mario
game which
i mean it was ridiculous to try to
because you know they they line you up
you got to have
pre-existing knowledge yes of some of
the levels to even get through it
yeah you know what i mean because they
you know just cause the way they do it
so i mean so that's that's as early as i
can
think think back wow where's games go
now as far as like again you said your
sister got you in the game
and the it was nes that she got you the
game with
that was the first one yeah okay cool
now at that age do you have any standout
stuff that you remember that you would
just play any games
that you would play on any yes like
non-stop like
what was somebody to stand up if you
remember or you're too young like what
was the
the system and the g and the games that
stood out to you the most
that you remember um probably
honestly probably it was probably sega
it's about that time like
i have way more memories of that and you
know like
uh the sega channel a lot of people
don't don't know what it is break it
down
basically so sega channel is like real
similar to game pass basically yeah
i don't know how they got it to work
because we didn't have the kind of tech
we got now
that you know back then so whatever you
you got it through your cable company
too
and it was like an adapter and it
literally worked the same way you get on
every month they would have 50 games on
there sometimes they swap games
in and out and then you you just play it
will be the full game
when the game was low and they give you
tips that's when you know
pretty much everything all the classics
was on there
your next there was games like vector
man i remember like
horror games that nobody's ever going to
beat the lion king
yes um
black king flintstones uh
double dragon gold knacks freeza rays
um madden was on there they had a couple
other sports games
jeopardy family feud telling you they
had
and that's when i found um like some uh
my first rpgs got star heroes
you know you know when i purchased into
the sega channel and uh
you're the only person i swear you know
what brought up the sega channel
and understanding it and knowing it is
is is
that you knew right now because you're
looking at tech now
you're like these dudes just caught up
to tech like that but sega was doing it
back then
there's a reason why a lot of people
have an affinity for sega because sega
was doing things
that other companies weren't doing or
weren't trying
and um it's just real it's crazy that
you even
mentioned the sega channel is nuts all
right so
you said the lion king which was nuts um
and you said vector man
right all right so you remember when you
first saw vector man you saw his moving
parts and it was all together
they were doing a like a ray tracing uh
uh
technology back then in that cartridge
and it's insane it's things that we're
missing but keep hitting me with that
knowledge because
that you just blew my mind right there
yeah
i'm like pocketwise they said you had to
be rich to get the sega chat no
no no no wait man wait what
ain't had no money
whoever it was made an executive
decision that
you can play with everything you know 50
games back then that's a hell of a lot
of money
all right and the decision was they
wanted to make you happy keep you
in a good safe space and have all these
extra games that you can play without
actually having to go out to the store
and spend because that's a lot of money
if you think about it those games are 70
80 dollars
easy easy yeah so you know to pay 60
dollars for that program
right i think it was like 69.99
something was there i thought it was
cheaper i wouldn't i wouldn't really
know
yeah but yeah like and it was like no
lag like
nothing i don't understand the tech for
that i'll never
that's a good thing what's your research
you know what it is often times
a lot the way they set up internet
uh for the masses right oftentimes the
speeds they can achieve
even years ago was much higher than what
they we were probably
right like the bandwidth seems like a
lot of the bandwidth always seems like
it's been there
it's just a matter of when they're ready
to roll it out to us and charge us an
arm and a leg for it that's a good break
yeah that's crazy so
i think your game in stride was probably
the n64 right because if i'm looking
at the ages i think gaming
you're like you're real like when you
was hitting your stride it was probably
like
n64 ryan 64 between that and then
the dreamcast then after that it was
just smooth selling all right
let me let me know because one thing i
want to ask you because one thing you're
known for
in your content is your knowledge of
these sports games and
sega in my opinion you know what i'm
saying was like
one of the de facto sports kind of
systems no disrespect to nintendo like
i felt like you were a sports enthusiast
like were you rocking
the nba lives were you rocking you know
what i'm saying like those type of
sports games ea sports games demands all
that back then or did you develop your
love for the sports game
later as you got into the playstation
area and all that stuff
so with the sports games you know you
can play those all year right right
and when you're younger like you don't
really care necessarily
right away if it's the new one right you
can play madden that's two years old you
don't really care
facts oh i definitely yeah sega nba live
and um there was a couple other like
give me something to cut with jordan
versus
um there was uh like what's it called
like
there was a game called jam it these are
all yeah
arch rivals oh that was the bully ball
joint yeah
there's another game but i think they
did a
a a new version in the last couple years
called music league football mutant
hockey oh you remember music
i played both of those games um
uh and then it was like simply there was
nfl 95 nfl 96
yeah i think those became like the 2k
games later i think but i'm not sure
so i remember all of those i play i play
all those on on sega
let me ask you a question yeah when you
got to your playstation
was you a fan of game day because we
always had a probably always always
trying to find a game that could beat
matters
i was the only dude in the store behind
the playstation game day yesterday
what about what about quarterback club i
love quarterback club
i love quarterback club that way was
that sony
989 yeah
cause we would play the night eight
night baseball we'll play the other
stuff but the football
nah that was like sacrilege to go there
did you get a chance to play joe montana
on your own on your genesis the sports
talk
yeah yeah for sure you know i noticed
though that a lot of them old games
was like i swear the gameplay was
exactly the same it just had a different
name yeah
exactly so i felt like the joe montana
was one of those games i felt like
two or three other football games at the
time yeah yeah
yeah you keep going now you get into
that you said you missed out on
playstation initially
one first one playstation one initially
right so when did you get
into the playstation ecosystem so i
didn't have a ps1
but like my cousin who lived right next
door to me had had so i always played
heads
the homies around and i used to get
laughed at bro
i'm gonna tell you look i know y'all
remember this was
this is the first big wrestling game
which one wwf
warzone oh oh yeah right yeah
so like i'm playing i'm excited right
and then like when when the characters
come out like the sound's a little weird
because it's
purchases but when i go over my cousin's
house and my boy house when they
music come out for the intros to the
ring it's like
actual song
they was laughing at me like yo why
yours i'm like man i don't know i didn't
really know
i guess the way the audio compression
worked between the disc and the
cartridge
right so yeah i always had a ps1 around
i just never
owned a ps1 but i you know i got to play
a good bit of ps1
and i got really got into to the uh the
playstation with the ps2
oh okay um remember that maddie when it
first dropped
on man i bro because i don't really care
for madden
really since like 12 maybe 13. okay um
i love madden man like people don't
understand people love 2k
yeah maybe not this year's game but yeah
we'll get it
but people love 2k but madden madden had
all they had the whole like the
barbershop everybody yes
everywhere you went dudes is playing you
have people at the house i have little
mini tournaments tournaments
man madden really like even the madden
bus when he used to come around and used
to go down to the stadium and
play you
will go to stadiums and pull up and then
and if you you know you get online or
whatever
and they have a limited amount of time
but you're a lucky kid to get inside to
play the new madden
yeah that's crazy yeah and they had it
they had a show mtv
yes and it's crazy because uh problem
got no problem right
yeah he was on there oh like that's how
long he's been
like killing people in madden he's won
the madden bowl
tournament i think they had like four
seasons that was a real great show i
really liked that [ __ ]
that was when like matt was really yeah
and then i don't know what happened
i feel like after the ps2 i just didn't
i just
it really is probably the micro
transaction yeah they got too many
and that became the focal point of
pretty much
any of the sports games if you ask me
you know what i'm saying
that's what's up yeah how to monetize
and how to take more money from you
because they they realize we were gaming
exclusively there like you said every
hood every barber shop every street
corner
dudes had that new man and then it was a
thing like before like
i only the way i can equate it to the
younger people now is like fortnight and
call of duty
yes this is what we were doing then like
that madden
and i had to bend the knee to this
because of game day like i said
game day i was in there and that's the
yeah i had to just check
my my my cd because i really thought
with the playstation 2 when it was
coming out because we slept outside that
day remember that
and they had a tv screen out there now
we would see it in magazines
but we really didn't see it till we saw
it moving
and they had the black eyes and they had
the little little shoulders they had
they're all the same face everybody had
the same face
but the models though i've never seen
nothing i've never seen nothing move
like that
i've never seen and and that was the i
said to hell with game day
this madden right here what year what
year do you think that was
on the cover the day had dropped we was
dead
i forgot number one yeah it was matt
like man no one maybe
no shout out to anonymous got that [ __ ]
some somebody knows what what
what what get what madden dropped
of playstation 2 is launched right
i want to know who it probably was
marshall i think it was marshall falcon
the cover
but he didn't look like that in the game
though
64. all right i remember that because i
was that was i think i might be the only
man where you could play
with the inside the helmet camera yes
right um
i remember all the characters i swear it
was like white
everybody every like if you if you would
go to the all man team
ray lewis and all these days all about
everybody was vital
to the dodd and melanin textures
yeah it was a revolution bro it was they
madden had it it was
not only was a phenomenon it was one of
the most popular things it had well i
will say
the chats bring up a good point though
the the decline started they started
getting saying me they started doing the
microchip transactions like chase is
saying
and then we can't front went
2k nfl was a 2k five
and then they started undercutting them
with the 20 dollars
so did that change the game because he
was like well i'm not going to pay
50 60 or whatever it was for madden when
this game just is good and i'll never
forget
king i think it was you you brought over
2k
5 and it had a halftime show
yeah and chris berman yeah and i was
like they doing replays
and i'm like oh my god it was better
than it was better than the whole time
the whole time yo i was i was like yo
this is the straight this is espn this
is
this is the tv and that's what we walked
away from that yeah because
bad ea was oh no we got to get the bike
i'm talking about like right right now
remember when i told you i played the
madden and i was just like it was like
little things that was missing
yeah and it's like the nostalgia that i
had like when you said
the halftime show with chris berman
right and then he's talking about the
stuff that you did in the first quarter
right you know and you like oh snap and
he
dropped back and he took the and i was
like yo they really
stopped that like they're telling you
little things that you can do
and um stuff and give you highlights but
they don't really have an announcer
pointing out the things that you know he
fumbled here and brett favre had to get
it together
yeah it's just like literally yeah yeah
definitely said espn football
it was that was the competition that was
when it was like oh it's on because
yeah sports they got they jumped with
the graphic fidelity at the dreamcast oh
yeah
they link with they linked with espn
right and then they linked with espn
then they came to console playstation
and then they was causing terror for man
like madden had to
get cut them out that 1999 thing really
broke
yeah that broke up yeah because they
went they used in 1999
across all sports genres yeah mm-hmm all
the joints that they did because i think
they had the espn for the baseball for
on the basketball as well right yeah
yeah so when that 1999 happened that's
what
that's what mattered
it was the nfl that brought up the i i
never confirmed it so i didn't know who
was responsible
i didn't care i just knew he wasn't
going to get a 2k football yeah man
we're just going to be able to
this is how we found out how contracts
work
and then they tried to do the one
without the license
that's what it was over that's what it
was that's the best game they made
though
the game was fired you're right chase
you remember remember when
mv they stopped making mvp baseball and
then they made the college baseball one
right afterwards
that was their technically their best
game it was better than mvp 2005 but
nobody cares about college players so no
you're absolutely you're right
baseball particularly especially when
you're playing a hot dog park
nobody cares about
you know i will say like like to some of
the stuff we were saying
like a lot more stuff excited us
obviously when we was younger
yes but we didn't have all the analyzing
that we do now so like
like there's been times where like you
you see a youtube video
it's something you ain't even notice yes
now you can't unsee it yeah
right there is this really great youtube
channel this guy's name is ryan moody
has anybody seen
any of his videos don't talk to me
you're gonna kill your nostalgia you're
murdering understanding nostalgia
ryan moody he uh he covers madden right
analyzes the game but everything he most
of what he's saying
has merit to it a lot of it is just
straight correct he will show you
player interactions how the offensive
and defensive line interaction has been
broken in madden
since like 2013. he's showing
like it's not you can't really argue
with a lot of the stuff because
he like showing eat stuff like this he's
seeing banners that say man 18
and in the game that's like man 20. oh
no
oh he you know whatever your king yeah
all right so check this out right so i'm
in my house what we do every saturday we
will watch karate flicks right
we will go to the um fordham road it
will be uh three for twenty dollars
right so we go buy three phones we all
chip in the money get the films
we all pick the films and we go home and
we watch it on saturday well this is one
saturday
i want one friday i'm watching it by
myself
and i paused it to get up and go get
something to drink
and when i paused it my man was at least
six foot five
when he did a front tuck he was five
foot two
i said what the hell and then i started
watching it with the eyes
i said oh my god so i had to bring it
back to the team once i brought it back
to the team
that's it didn't want they man
be caught with the stuntman bug right
and we found out by doing our research
that there was a house like let's say
it's a house of dragons whatever their
name was called
they actually developed stuntmen for
these movies yes
and they would they would associate
themselves with the said movie
so when young man go to do his moves
they
stunt man too
[Laughter]
man so basically what chase is
explaining is like
when your man booty or whatever that
does this channel
is he's showing the intricacies of the
ai the offensive line right
and all the stuff that really wow
anybody that's been playing man long
enough uh you you know
it's it's stuff's pretty big especially
with the nanos and every like the
e-books and the e-guides
that the youtubers put out you can't
play games the way they're meant to be
designed you have to play the meta of
the
competitive players who are very good at
the game and they
give it all to the community now you
have to play their game right not the
developers game
right wow that's crazy man this is man
if it feels like that that that's what
happened on destiny man we don't
we don't play pvp the way bungie's meant
to play we played the way glass meant to
play it
yeah man it's real it's really it goes
to show you you know how the problem
with i think annualizing franchises and
and not having an enough window for
development right because let's be in
defense of the developer
you know how much really more can you
improve and innovate
on such as a tight schedule not even a
year right so yeah
it's not a long development cycle and
then i remember and i'm gonna talk some
real
intricate metatarsal for a minute when i
was right quantum men they would do
things that were really annoying that's
when i started to fade out because
i don't know if you remember this chase
there was a a
feature it was called like defensive
assignment in madness
and like back then y'all said cornerback
is my favorite position of football
right
so i was like oh my charles what's in
you know what i'm saying like whoever
the best overall ninety-nine
you know what i'm saying like i'm gonna
put my corner on your best
player in head to head when i'll be on
on the tournaments whatever i
love that feature so i was like oh this
is fire like this is
so what would happen is like the next
year certain features would magically
disappear that was one of them
others would come about and i'm like
what's going on the same thing with the
quarterback cone
one year is here one year so it just to
me like
where i started to get frustrated was
regression of features
right right and then again not
innovating
it just starts to become samey just a
new kind of paint
just the rosters really change so at
that point you might also just keep the
same game and just do a roster update
but they want to make money that's what
people so there's two things
so first thing i don't know if y'all
know this i don't know if y'all keep up
with competitive man did y'all see the
foolishness from last year
no break it down okay and this is what i
like
i understand if you like madden a lot of
people that like men love ultimate team
right without that mode just the
gameplay madden is not a good game right
ultimate team is fun it is like the
model for
how to do content maybe not the
monetization but the actual mode is good
right last year the madden ball winner
drafted a punter no to put that
quarterback
it handed the ball off every single play
for
every single game in the tournament one
of the games he handed off the ball
92 times and he won with a puncher
why do you have a punter he picked a
left-handed puncher
to put our quarterback because
left-handed players hand the ball off
faster
wow and the reason he had a punter is
because they do the drafts for their
players or their teams
with like uh like a um
kid everybody is spending their money at
quarterback right he just spending his
money
and he has more money to actually put a
fro a front line
so he can run and he can actually break
man that's smart
yeah look he these are not bombs these
are
great they'll watch everybody in the
stream wow
we're talking about this one
the best players in the world cannot
stop a guy from running a ball
every play with a punter at quarterback
and the same guy that did that
he's been competitive he had never won
so he's he's been around
no restrictions on the tournament that's
not a restriction
within the game it was on tv it was on
tv they they i don't there's never an
excuse
wow to have your game showcased that way
grabbing on tv
that's it for reflection that you gave
think about it right i mean regardless
to what
it this is this is what i like when
people say that you know
well he's cheating people he's not
cheating right if he did what he did
all you got to do is validating why i
never got into sports
i mean i hear what you're saying but all
right so you're giving a budget
logic dictates i get it you will use
your budget because we are trained to
believe that the quarterback
is the most essential part of your team
right baby but what he did was
he took that logic and turned it on top
of his head
he said because we do not value the
punter at all
so what he did was he found value in the
punter because he realized the left hand
if he's handing it off you're right he's
getting the ball the left-handed
you know he's gonna get out of his hand
faster than the right-handed punter
right yeah get the little
cheap exploit
listen money plays on us all day
they talk crazy to us so these are all
about
he's not he's not cheating he's not
cheating he played with the game and the
rules of the game
definitely yeah he's not cheating
he's not cheating let me ask you a
question
and see if i'm right because i don't
know anything about this right if i'm
right
he used the rest of his money to shore
up
his center his uh left guard
and his right tackle right i'm not sure
where he
put it but it's possible that he
he funneled that into making the run
game but that would be that would be the
wise thing to do
right saved all this money on the
quarterback which is probably one of the
most expensive
yeah yeah and have a good blocking with
your title which is
crazy that's great let me ask you guys i
was going to say
pretty much like by the time people
caught on it was too late it was over
all right i got comparison right because
that's that's i just wanted
that's 100 exploit right he
they have rules they have things that
you are not
allowed to do right when you play games
in competitive
and i bet you that i bet you this is
nude this is something
so that right there should have been
established that you can't do that
for example call of duty which is a
completely different game
right there's certain guns kill streaks
and setups
that is not loud in the game right
because they know
that this is going to be misused right
that should have happened
in man i don't know if that would be
fair for them to say hey you can't draft
a punter
like how are you going to tell him but
that that's the the pretty much the run
game was overpowered
as it was right the community knew but
he just found that mix it up with
another little thing
he ran the ball 92 times say like the
best of the best
can't stop it i did it on national
television i showcased your gameplay
yeah it's but it's an embarrassment to
them and that's
and that's exactly and that's the
problem man i played madden 06 franchise
for a walk through last year
at the end of last year it was so fun i
created a whole team
i was able to name custom jerseys custom
stadiums
creative fan all that stuff's gone from
the game they don't
and then they haven't touched
franchising in years that's why i
stopped messing with it here's the
regression of features and not yet
and then they lie one year they said
they couldn't give the pro ball players
individual helmets because they couldn't
do it
and then they had it like the next year
that's the problem
right let's say this right because we
all know now
now that we're older yeah and we all do
actually follow the development of games
and stuff like that
and we say a turnaround basis is from
six months that's why
we look forward to new consoles and new
generations
because usually what the uh the company
do is like they scrap their old
um engine and they go up to a new engine
and this is when we get the benefit of
new stuff and probably by the second or
third year
they can implement all the stuff that
they wanted to implement before right
but
while we're in the generation we notice
that
they don't really have that much time
yeah so there's stuff that's on the
board
and stuff that they can't implement at
that time because there's a real crunch
when it comes to sports game facts
so my question to you do you think that
sports games
should take a two year to three year uh
come out
and just give roster updates or is it
because
the the monetization of the money is too
high
that they won't do it well it's
definitely the monetization's too high
you've seen that revenue right yes sir
from ultimate team alone
for them to say we're not going to do
that this they're not they're not going
to do that
now now for for the best scenario for us
i think it would be better if they did
it a minimum two years
right um to give them a full because
what happens is if we complain about
something this year we're not gonna
probably see it fixed until
two games later yeah we're already you
know two months after
the new game comes out they're already
in development for the next one right
right our feedback might not
be you know something that they can do
right so i do think
like for our thing every two years i'm
sure people get excited but if they did
a roster update but they
they could also do meta changes and meta
shifts and right because they can change
the game play
tremendously and we've seen it yeah
people
are still playing fortnite they're
playing they've been playing pub g
they've been playing destiny they've
been playing all these games for
years in a row so to me that says that
people will
continue to play but you have to vastly
change the game and roll out content and
meta changes
um like look at overwatch yeah overwatch
is starting to get their community back
because they fixed the queue times i
jumped back on there
right but like you know people been
playing that's the plan
i think i think they could get away i
think i think what it is is
ea's over there is like look like i get
it you guys want this
but we making the money already
or or what they should do is like call
of duty does
they have different differences
developing
the games to give one studio that year
off
to develop for the next year yeah
it works better i know some people don't
like um like uh
different studios doing they call the
duty and they skip that yeah
yeah but um i think i think that'll be
the best way to go i mean
make it competitive i that the license
is available to all
so that you know sega does make their
game and we can have that
their competitive choice their
competitiveness would push madam because
i hear what you're saying like features
was lost but all these features that you
love the most is when these dudes had
competition
yeah then there's no comp and this goes
back to like console wars and all this
other stuff
yeah long is this competition right
right it had to be done
going back to the sega channel like you
said sega had to do that because
nintendo was breaking their back
they had to come out with something in a
competitive form that actually will get
people to go that way
so yeah competition breeds excellent
again i think
instead of like it clearly attacking ea
ain't going to do nothing at this point
because ea just going to keep doing what
ea loves doing
gotta be attacking the nfl and get and
get that license out to
more people so they have to to compete
well they did
the 2k but it's not it's not a it's not
a sim game remember
as much as i love seeing the show on
xbox that's what worries me about
that game now like because now we just
have xbox but then
they go on a pc they probably went to
this place i don't
i have a pc i don't want to play co-op
um
they're cheaters it's not everybody but
it's enough of it when you banned 500
000 people
and one month from war zone you know
they got night vision goggles on war
zones
that's a new thing the pc community has
found a hack to wear
night vision goggles and warzone why
would i
play with people like that bro
you're like got him we gotta move on we
doubled history but i gotta ask my
question because i was meeting
just quickly if you could answer this
because i've been out of the 2k scene
and i was one of my favorites you know
what i'm saying to my player i just need
to add
is is the badge situation still sheisty
is the competitive seated nba 2k
somebody to stay away from
we're about to go down and compete
i have i have one question for you and
then i'll tell you okay did you do did
you play
the new the next gen game at all yes
okay do you know about the the 82 bash
build no i do not
okay so that's the problem that's the
problem i'm gonna just
82 badges no elite dribble moves
elite contact dunks plus three-pointer
90-plus ball handle
90-plus speed power forward
six seven so when you when you go to the
park yeah
you lucky if you don't run into three of
them
when you have a belt like that who needs
a point guard
you're not going to have you got the
same four of these in the center
badges there's a certain building
i thought and then the zens console
players got their zenith now on the
games with the chronos
so there's that so like there's just so
much cheating but we get we can we go
we're going to talk about we're going to
talk because i need to holla at you
i was like i know chase going to give me
the
look we got to get into your content
creation part you know one thing we love
about let's get those likes up yeah
chase out here you know what i'm saying
so like yo at the end of the day like i
want to talk about his content creation
give me
one second yeah no do it get the cake
get the cake get
so yeah just in reference to this
content creation one thing we love about
him he is
hilarious on stream always brings the
energy so like what
made you like fuse because a lot not a
lot of casters doing it like
fusing comedy and the vibes into your
street yeah
not quite like you not like you you want
to hold up
i do feel like like there are a lot of
like you know comedy-centric shadows in
gaming but
none of them do it like chase thank you
uh honestly i mean when you first
started man like
well well so this is so basically when
you break down people's content it's
usually people
they do like um information tutorials
you got those people you got the review
people
um you have the people that are great at
the game
like but normally you don't get people
that are like
like either three all three of those or
two out of three it's usually like one
facts so i knew from like a review
standpoint i wasn't really trying to get
too much into that you know y'all know
how
like who's get salty you say something
about the game
um they're like those you know they'll
uh give you strikes on your channel and
this this i'm off like ea
people like that wow um so yeah i i
didn't want to deal too much with that
uh info is cool but
um i felt like there's people that are
better at that so it's like yo i just
need to try to just be entertaining and
that's what it came on
like if you can be entertaining you
could pretty much you know you can you
could stay in that lane and do that
i wasn't really going to fit the other
stuff as much so i was just like i'll
just do this
plus me my friends we always climbing
around that's all we did anyways we just
did that
yeah you know what i mean and just
pretty much chill and do that because
like i know i know
i'm not god's here at the game so i
won't even attempt to do that
i need to just i need to just chill let
people have a good time you know i mean
they stopped by for 10 minutes maybe
that's having a rough day let me give
them a little laugh and they go on about
their day fat bro you kill that man
there's one thing
i like about what you do one you're not
afraid to make fun of yourself if you're
not good at a certain thing
the funny thing remind me of being my
peeps coming up we used to play
2k like 2k is a funny game to play
especially when you got
teammates that they doing what they
supposed to do because i see you rage as
somebody
yeah they wouldn't bother me hot like yo
what you doing you you
shot like four shots you shot a airborne
what's going on
like that's the type of stuff i think
about actually yeah that's actually one
of the funniest things because i don't
care about basketball i don't care about
football
but would you watch like chase or other
people play this time like
it don't even matter because you're
there to watch the game
interactions like sometimes some of the
funniest things i see is when they're in
the park
and then they going at each other more
than playing because
it's funnier that all the park teammates
going at each other
that's what we do that's just that's
just
that's what i do the part of the
internet that part of the internet's
problem is people don't know how to
laugh that day some facts
everybody want to laugh at somebody you
know but then when the [ __ ] demographics
turn on your turn now you want to be
awesome
to you on here crying you throwing like
personal life shots because somebody
said something to you in the video
[Laughter]
chase has like it feels like our our ray
day one
yes oh that is so fun so we've argued
for an hour we've argued for an
hour but this is my boys
we know when this is over nobody cares
but right now i can't believe you shot
that
like you see the score you shot that
it's always the same dude
but i promise you in the clutch if the
game is tired or we down two and we need
a three
twenty seconds left my brother carter is
going to shoot a
crazy shot shut up
he was going to shoot he like if you
play 2k enough they got they got there's
levels of the contest
yeah if you're 100 smothered
uh
[Laughter]
so chase yeah you guys play a lot of the
you guys play simulation stuff but you
could ever play really get into like the
nba jams and stuff like that
because the nba jams there's a lot of
game just cheats a lot right so yeah
it makes for some really really tense
situations
um you ever really get into those it was
mostly just simulation stuff
not not so much like nba gym
there was some wwe uh
you know we do play other arcadey stuff
there was some of that
uh but man dudes
they're doing different stuff because
two cases they're nobody's really
playing the game
yeah yeah so you know rp
gta rp they doing that and you know it's
crazy since they do it every year
it's like when they saw like oh man they
don't like that oh they ain't playing
that [ __ ]
they'll be back next year
so chase i come from double dribble
right right so
the thing in double dribble when you go
into the hole when you get a dunk
then you come from the side it'll go up
and go bam bam bam bam you get you're
done
right so when turbo graphics came out
they came out with this game called take
it to the hole
right now the difference between double
dribble and take it to the hole was
double dribble the dunk would be one
dude yeah but if you get to the hole
if your man went up to contestant he was
in the shot and he got
dunked on you know that's one
feature i miss i don't know if they can
bring that
back like that oh what contact don't
yeah but it was like cinematic contact
yeah no
2k this year's 2k because in the
previous years
somebody gotta take over slash to take
over right like you know you might you
you don't know
you might somebody might get done so
they might fall right
it didn't happen a lot right so when it
happened
we didn't laugh at the homie
see this is what i'm saying like chase
like in the game it stays in the same
game engine
right right this joint will jump out of
into a new energy
it was like a cinema it was like a
player like
the cinema yeah of them going up
[Music]
was that the one where when you go up
for that cinema you ha
it's like a bar that you have yeah you
put your hand up to block it
right right right yeah yeah and you just
you get done and they just
like you dunk and then like you fall a
little pullback with your feet but
this year it's too many contact dogs we
don't even react anymore if somebody
gets dunked on and falls you see it so
often so
you just just inbound the ball nobody
says anything
to it yeah real quick to switch gears
also the thing i want to give you
probably i love
what you do with your let's plays i got
to talk about this is what you know
for bro like you would yo you got to see
a kid
he's doing this harlem with the lord joy
he played like he gets into the
character like
what is that like
sometimes i'll be looking at that chaser
like is that like a green screen is he
really guiding
this stuff oh no it's all yeah
i'm worried i did i was joking around i
forgot what you're doing you go to party
city
or not you gotta go on amazon wherever
that's now look
i was on the cosplay sites and it said
that joining was 400 i closed the tab
bro
cosplay outfits credit cards they on
point they gonna take
two months to get there and then it will
be four hundred dollars so
always go on amazon and see whatever
they have either that party city
he'd be having some crazy stuff yeah oh
man
yeah that was a that was the first one i
was just messing i said i'm gonna wear
this you know what i mean
um and you know just full people see
that though yeah
uh i need it i need is a business
expense
we could probably get to that too
because people are stuff that people
don't know about why streamers spend all
the money spent on packs oh yeah they
get right off
yeah so i was trying to get tax
write-offs because i talked to the
accountant and she was like yeah i was
like so if i buy costumes that's like
all tracks
yeah so yeah so i did it now and then
people's like yo this hilarious my blog
so there every once in a while i would
just do it you know what i'm saying and
then i
then i at some point i was like i'm
supposed to get the most ridiculous
impossible that's that's why i'll be
looking at this and i'll be like
that can't be real man like that's some
crazy looking stuff
yeah yeah so that's pretty much what
what it is
sometimes the costume is real tight real
hot yeah
i had the spiderman only had one zipper
in the back
oh man let me tell you let me tell you
how i rigged the costume
i had to put like a don't judge me
because look this is what i do when i
was wearing a spiderman costume i had my
girls hit me up before she go to work
oh no and i couldn't like i like it took
a minute to zip it off
yeah you guys like man i'm gonna have to
cut a hole right there
i go on youtube i swear to goodness bro
i typed in
how to zip up a dress because i'm like
at that moment i'm like woman they
really they really do do this
they do this with no help right so i'm
like how are they so i go on youtube and
i seen the video
the shorty had the zipper she put a a
shoe string through the zipper held it
like this is right
oh with a paper clip let me do it it
worked
good shout out to that google yeah
it was either
you laid out
and i gotta watch because she likes to
open up the curtains downstairs in the
morning
so i can't be walking through the house
because like this jacket is all free
could you imagine your neighbor look at
the crosses you see you pass on this
look that would be that's more that's
not as bad as like the assassin's creed
like you look in the window and like i
have like the flintstones caveman outfit
i cannot explain that
that's like amazing videos i could just
see now you it's like a skit with
with chase open the door it's the
mailman he's like what's possible
[Laughter]
[Music]
last question i got for you on gmg you
know what i'm saying
what is why you getting into podcast
game with the homies and stuff like that
i believe 3mg the homies on this still
right or no yeah
okay no doubt that salute so this
man this is like the end of 2012.
because i
i didn't even make the name but like i
was a guest on the podcast oh okay
originally one uh one of my guys by the
name of aaron
um and there was another guy named patty
patty was actually from ireland too so
he used to be up
real late with us but um he hit me up
he's like i'm trying to do a podcast
and i was like man i don't really you
know i don't really know i said sure
i'll try
and originally it was on um uh
log talk radio because what it was
called
so that was like hey you know would you
what you do and i was like sure i'll do
it
and we was doing it on there for a while
they already had the name and everything
and then um those they had life stuff
happen so they really couldn't do it
anymore by that time i was like man i'm
just moving this over to youtube so that
was 2013 when i moved it over
okay and that's just been pretty much
like that ever since yeah absolutely man
i love you getting in the game
tremendous podcast tremendous history
love that thank you fun brother you
always had a good time
and he's always feel good vibes man like
we're kind of like in the middle from
not being in this toxic community to
being in this type of community
yeah so it's it's nice that like there's
still people out there that that's doing
games
and doing content how games were
designed to have fun
right yeah that's the only reason i'm on
here i'm going to keep doing your thing
i gotta ask you you know what i'm saying
we asked all the lords of the realm of
the guests
i need that lord chase money top five
video games or franchises of
all time that's such an unfair question
swear to god like the if somebody said
top five per gin
even that would be hard but i could
probably do that top all right i can't
eat
this no no i'm gonna do it the way you
ask you know what i'm saying
so i'm already knowing that i'm gonna
leave out
because if i had a real list it'd have
to be probably about 40 games
yeah in fact easily facts so
there's gonna be games that i'm not
going to say that doesn't mean they're
really not my top five
i'm not thinking about it of course how
fast let's do franchise let's do
franchise let's go
um
i mean i feel like it's a little hanger
fruit i'm gonna say god of war okay okay
that's one um yeah
i didn't really like the fifth game but
metal gear solids too
uh you like snake eater that was my
mother that's my favorite that's my
favorite
one of my favorites probably when he was
at his pinnacle
yeah i agree uh didn't really like the
third game as much but kingdom hearts
man was if i wasn't not already not
following chase he can follow right now
kingdom hearts that's the first he did
yeah yeah that's the song
that's three three
two more mario gotta do maria
i wouldn't even be playing games that's
what i'm saying honestly
i'm subbing to chase money right now i
got it that's right you sucked
man
if you click on my channel uh turn it
down loud
it's loud it's loud i love it i'm loud
too they get mad at me they're like
you're too loud i'm loud i'm sorry i
left a lot
yeah i know this this today today he he
bust the gun
i bust a gun today one
more one more franchise
it means you have to chase this even if
you know something
it's got to be massive yeah you got to
be something like that
i don't even want to do any sports games
honestly
man this is tough look look at king
trying to get himself up
i'm just saying you know the only reason
why i would say like you know
a sports franchise only a couple of
weirdos out there that like that
honestly i i really don't care for
madden since yeah
yeah sister it was a
that was a big part of my yeah man it
was a big part coming out of my
childhood
just because i'm kind of stuck a little
bit i'm gonna say i'm actually gonna say
man i know that sounds crazy because
i'll do all i do is trash the game yeah
but it's trash it out it's it's like
that's with destiny
we talk mad stuff because we care we
want the game to go in a better place
yeah that's exactly and that's exactly
where it is yeah because if
if it's good it could be amazing you
know what i'm saying you'll
they had the biggest black eyes i've
ever seen in the game like they was all
running around on drugs
but i that's when i realized
the spectacle that madden was like
that's what i realized
and final question favorite console of
all time any generation
ps2 purely because of the library
in my opinion like obviously
in the era of multiplayer that's a
different conversation
but just like single player single
player library yeah
that library on playstation was out of
control a lot of games that became
multi-plats
eventually were only ps2 games that
library was
massive and we got to remember that's
when games were cheaper they
they would experiment more that's when
we had like the best version of eea
and yeah stuff like that and then like
all the definitions of games
but that's when people like from the
playstation 1 to the playstation 2
i think the playstation 2 was the best
designed playstation console
right from the standpoint that console
when you got it it was heavy it was
robust it was well designed
we really didn't have any problems with
you know like we have problems with
consoles and stuff like that now
no no we had no problems we got your
playstation you was rocking your
playstation yeah
your memory cards and stuff i remember
going to the store getting extra control
to get your memory card
oh i got an amendment we gotta get
madden out of here gta man
[Applause]
the library in their playstation that's
when they was
that was i think that was the sweet spot
even though
the playstation 1 started it the
playstation 3 had their little issues
and stuff like that
and they and they really took it to the
next level but that playstation 2 i
think that solidified
them being a real player in this game
yeah and another key
component that helped them is just like
at that time sure there was other
competitors
there but they were new uh so they had
they had pretty much the whole industry
under them at that time
games that normally would not have been
an exclusive word exclusive because
where else you gotta go
they had the pulse of japan they had
that and
and they had the attention of the
of us the west because the tvs was
banging at they time
i remember getting the hd one because
they had playstation 2
they had the trojan horse yes the dvd
player the dvd
yes they did because remember that was
the easy way for the hood to get into
the dvd game
they always did that though yeah they
always did that from cd to the others
they always did that they become a
multi-function device just off rip
you would you were stupid to get a
standalone at that point you might
just get a playstation at that point
yeah i said no i'm not buying no dvd
where i got a playstation 2. get out of
here
tremendous history man chase killed that
let's get the pole we get the super
chats then we get the topper
so last last week's poll results are
in and the people spoken to the question
when review scores are finally released
on a highly anticipated game
if the score from some media outlets are
lower than expected how does this
affect your opinion of these outlets the
winner of the poll
at a commanding eighty percent of the
vote was reviews are subjective i only
care about the overall impressions and
will decide myself
come in at second place at 60 was i have
to question the integrity of the outlaw
outlet and the reviewer especially if
there is a disparity
and in last place at three percent of
the vote was the petty lords i don't
care
my whole existence is tied to the review
score i'm gonna throw my
credit score in your face shout outs
shout out to the three percent we'll put
that down lowest son what's your
thoughts sir and then let's get some
jets
yeah listen man i don't i don't care
about aggregate scores i really don't i
give if the general public is just
saying something is trash then yeah i'll
listen obviously
but you know as you know me i'm a
collector of games i don't play games i
just
buy them and collect them so uh yeah i'm
gonna make my own decision
a hundred percent of the time fair
enough enough so i was getting super
chats before we started the topics
all right i got a question after we do
that yeah what's up bro
uh just about the review score what do
you want me to do now
no yeah okay let's go question i a quick
question what is the game that everybody
in here liked
and the review scores weren't the
highest maybe not trash no but maybe
not good yeah like maybe maybe yeah
maybe it was a 70
73 or something like my destiny dying
light
down light i love dying light it's one
of the most unready games
period mm-hmm mad max
i love mad max as well okay crack down
okay
i'm glad you said that because again
when i was talking to people about like
diversity and titles and sometimes it's
not about
just having blockbusters all the time
because it's those
diverse titles where you get a new
player
into your ecosystem that would not rock
with your ecosystem to hear you say
you didn't really walk with xbox at the
time but sunset overdrive was a title
that said yo
i was just waiting he was waiting for
something
it serves them right for what's about to
happen to them
with that said title it serves them
right for not supporting it
and unfortunately yeah so when it goes
over to the playstation uh
uh ecosystem good for you you know what
they're saying right they're saying that
it's not
there really are no plans if they if you
look at what the team is playing
i could almost see that that's a lot
it's more like it's more like haha look
what we got
sony
like literally uh you know budgeting
that whole thing
funding that whole game just for the
memes like just
i mean i think for i think with that
game
they're trying to explore if they can do
a remake of the actual game i don't
think they can
so then if it's funding a two i mean a
two is damn sure possible
that can happen but if they can do that
the actual first game and we got it i
don't think they can do it i love the
first one but i wouldn't put it past
someone
microsoft published it right i wouldn't
put it without sony to do it too
i really just would unless unless
there's some type of like
contract saying they can't do anything
uh of sunset overdrive
but if if if they can i have a feeling
in the next like two years we'll see you
soon
no they will get my money off there yeah
yeah no they will get my money off that
because i thought that was like like you
ain't gonna wait for it to go to the
playstation now
no i don't have a playstation now
hell no
we got uh stitch with the three dollar
super chat hello guest
panel and that guy addict that's
interesting
disrespectful oh we got black road in
five dollar super chat sega channel was
dope first time
but the down low speed was make a meal
wait times also
affordable yeah we didn't we didn't
realize that at the time no we didn't
care though
then we have the ever born saga five
dollars absolutely
what is this sega channel you speak of
and why have i never heard of it i'm a
sega og and i thought i was up on again
nah
you playing but a lot of people didn't
know about it i
i have no clue what you guys thought a
lot of dudes didn't know about the sega
pico
yeah that was just marketed just for
kids yeah yeah that's true
oh then we got pixel bit g five dollar
super chat no commodore 64.
fourth in inches love anybody play that
fourth yes of course
listen he wasn't talking about that he
said he came in on super nes
he wasn't talking about back when we was
doing stoning stuff that's me
[Laughter]
play the let me see most technical
football game of his era shout out to
the lords and happy mother's day
day to the moms out there no doubt thank
you sir
then we got uh m marquis with the 25
super chat thank you so much i started
watching the show a little over three
months ago i figured it was time to put
in
on this man put in on this man
many thanks for the laughs and continue
to thrive thank you so much
and we got post up with the five dollar
super chat the nfl didn't want their
product to be viewed as cheap yeah i
remember that narrative too it was like
as good as the game was they were like
why are you selling it for twenty
dollars
one year they met the needle they did it
was a twenty
then we got king one supreme two dollar
super chat chase on iop
oh my goodies
then we got scrub there's five dollar
super chat shout out to the lords chase
money and the chat
y'all got me dying right now a lot of
jokes bro
then we got jb golden five dollar super
chat ps2 was definitely a goat but it
it definitely had less it had lesser
issues on where it stopped reading on
either dvds or blue cd discs yeah
i never had that problem though
but that was the laser right that was
when you have to take the lasers
i remember when people started doing you
remember the remember that the the dvd
cleaner disc that had the little
the brush thing that was the rush for it
that was the worst
yeah oh who knew yeah
[Music]
xbox and microsoft deserve all the crap
they would get if sunset overdrive comes
out on playstation
and i'm an xbox fan but they was dumb
not to back it better
i don't know are you prepared
for what i heard the fans wasn't buying
the game the deal was this
this was the deal they started from the
inception of the game
we'll make a game for you but we want to
own ip
and microsoft was like they were in a
situation where
different regimes different people okay
we want you we just want the game
yeah they probably saw the game and it
was lit and it was just like okay yeah
i mean this stuff turns around to bite
you for sure and i think what chase says
is very true
also back then you remember like i i i
don't mean to generalize right
but the xbox game player up until that
point was kind of known as
the shooting the shootie box whatever
i think game pass has conditioned us to
be more accepting of different types of
genres
yeah you do think that yeah now finally
that's why i was like they should have
greenlit a sunset overdrive too because
like
you have to condition people to play
yeah you can't just like that's all we
say about the jrpgs you can't give us
like a good game every now and then and
then expect your fan base to like them
when we're getting literally like
we're getting raw gems and we're not
getting anything else that's why getting
past the perfect play because then it's
like okay
now i'll people will say i'll try this
because i feel like i'm getting away but
i ain't paying for it
so now i can you know what i'm saying
well people don't like my whole
reference when it comes to a buffet
because some people eat at crappy
buffets that's their business but um
i'm talking about like if you ever been
to a buffet in california really
actually fine dining people yeah you
know going to these little compost
oh i'm just saying when you get a chance
to try different things you're more
apt to try different things when
everything's already paid for
you know you like if same thing with a
movie pass you got a movie pass
you're seeing all the blockbusters in
the movies like let me go see this
little indie film over here in the
corner
because i have the time you know look at
you yeah that's that's why it's good to
see like
because personally i end up liking the
the
lesser um popular games more not all the
time obviously we have the the big boys
you have you have your gears and
you gotta warn all that outside of those
i end up liking like the
you know the games i sell 700 000 a
million a million and a half
right or than the other ones because
they just seem to be more complete games
right so to see a lot of those games
make it over to game pass and to see
more people playing yakuza or
morning and all that it's good to see
because like these
these are great games and i think the
games we get now
are so safe yup yeah you know it's nice
to see games that take more risks when
you get
got it what i mean to the smaller game
to something because i agree
and i feel a lot of the indie scene the
double a scene they
they're more apt to take risks that's
where their innovation is they try
innovative things like yo the other the
games ain't doing this because they're
so scared they want to keep it safe
they want to try to protect they bad but
do you think that's a condition of the
industry
yeah like because all right we all vote
with our dollars here right
and we are more apt to buy these triple
a titles
right you know these these games like
resume evil 8 is hyped up i'm not buying
resonating weight i'm buying that bio
mutant yeah and the reason why i'm
buying behind me
i waited for so long for biomeeting to
show up
and the fact that i'm seeing the
gameplay and stuff that i want from it
i'm gonna get that
i'm gonna get around to resident evil
eight but like chase said
that was this that's a safe spot because
you already know when you're getting you
in the same spot right but
bio mutant it could it could be i don't
want to get too excited
but i look at that and i get zelda vibes
yes
and i'm like man
yeah yeah you know what's uh another
good example of a you know a double a
game that
that breaks boundaries that most like
jrpgs don't do
it was octopath travelers like like i
definitely didn't pick that up on the
switch because like sixty dollars that
was
paid that was kind of intimidating
because i'm looking at it and i'm like
yo
mario's 60 an octopath 60. i don't know
about this but
now since it came over on game pass
right yeah i probably would have waited
for like a deep deep discount sale
and i played it on gay price i'm like i
probably should have paid 60 for this
two years ago
oh we got one more we got jw is a shell
with the five dollar super chats
happy mother's day fellas i donate more
but the irs is still processing my
refund since
march 1st but let us owe one of them
money right
[Laughter]
so we caught up we're good yeah we're
crying let's get into these topics shall
we fly through these
um lord addict man this is you man or
the new that
village is out there in the wild your
time that you want to talk about
yeah so so yeah resident evil
uh village is it's finally out you know
i'm still i'm gonna say right now i'm
still
a little bit against the first person
aspect i don't know why it's still
ethan's growing on me a little bit more
in this than he did the other one
uh i feel i don't know how he got hands
he keep he keep losing
his whole head whole limbs in the last
one on chase stream yeah he's getting
stuff bit off in this one and somehow
he's still
he and you know what's funny this is so
normal to eat that like what when when
he thought he got up he's like i'm gonna
just wrap it up like
yeah i listen i don't know i'm not there
with you on ethan because he
he's surprised by everything like this
hasn't happened to him before he's like
what's going on what are those things
it's a freaking way and so but but but i
do want to point out
that this game is not resident evil
village this game is resident evil
4
because i'm sitting there i'm doing this
part at the beginning where i'm running
and i'm sitting and like what's funny is
i i watched chase's uh
uh stream after i did it and he's like i
think they want me to kill everyone
i'm like like i didn't even think that
because i remember playing resident evil
4
and they want you just to run around so
i'm just obviously spoilers my bad it's
the beginning of the game you guys got
to deal with it
and i'm just sitting here this is a
spoiler podcast
i'm just sitting here i'm sitting here
like this is literally resident evil 4.
is it the big deal with the the axe code
like this is literally resident evil 4.
so obviously chase i saw you streaming a
little bit of it
what's your impressions of it so far for
as much as you play this is resident
evil
like it i mean it's fun i i play those
games
because they want me to play i would
never i'll feel you i'm with you play
that
without you know because all the screams
and the random oh
boy yeah you know i i had not i've not
touched that
it is they they did the environment and
all that and the
you know the um the anxiety they did a
good job putting that together because
you know like
the thing about a good horror game it's
not just like
filling it with jump scares right it is
to have the person
kind of on edge right right
you're like what the hell right you
don't just keep throwing stuff in
loud sound effects that's not that's not
a good game
i feel like they're doing a good job so
far um you know but i do agree with like
he's just like what is this and i'm like
you just dealt with this
yeah you know you know what i love the
demo
you know what i love that and i don't
even do them they did that was funny
because i knew
people were talking about this like how
does this ethan dude have like
training he knows how to shoot guns and
stuff and they're like they literally
did oh we did we did uh we did trading
i'm like oh
so now you want to put that in there
they tried to slip that in there like oh
he's been trained by chris redfield huh
yeah it doesn't seem like it that's for
sure
but it's yeah it's just it's like i
think the game's
a solid experience like to me i it's
like chase said it
it's resident evil like and the whole
first person i'm still
not a hundred percent there i guess it's
okay i feel like it's one of those like
assassins creed scenarios where
they had to change it up or they're
gonna lose it so you know i guess
i personally felt like the third person
aspect wasn't the issue
it was the garbage direction they were
taking the franchise was the issue
and now it seems like they got the
direction and they feel like the success
is the first person aspect
it's like no it's not it's the fact that
you try to incorporate a little bit more
of
you know a scare tactic into this game
and i think that was the issue i think
it's more horrifying in the first person
um perspective of the game uh because
remember we was complaining about the
controls
on the third person aspect of it and you
know they they went away from the clunky
tank light controls
and it gave us more of an analog feel
but when you got that stuff
yeah yeah what you did with that was
you took away uh the fear because he was
fighting with the controls before so
that was more of your horrifying thing
and you would have one enemy on the
screen to two enemies on the screen
now with the better control he was able
to put more enemies on the screen
and it turned into like how many
monsters we can get to get them
this this first person thing you are
really immersed in i told you i was
terrified with that playstation vr
i don't care what nobody says real yeah
crazy so when it came on xbox i was i
was so more than happy to buy it
i was like i'm not i don't have to play
this in vr because i mean if you have vr
and you're playing on a playstation you
want to
use what you got yeah i get that
but i feel like they could like okay
first off there's werewolves in this
game
obviously that was in the trailer so i'm
not spoiling anything
and clearly i think homegirl the big
giant chick that everyone can't get
enough
of beautiful like i think she's a
vampire
i'm looking at like they put werewolves
in this game there's a giant
like lady in this game that i think so a
vampire
i'm like where did werewolves come from
all the resident evil games there wasn't
a werewolf but now there's a werewolf
they're supposed to be they they're
taking it to where i want it to be
this is okay this is my problem of
contention here this is the reason why
i'm playing seven
because i want to finish seven so i can
get to eight right and i don't wanna do
these things because
they're actually taking it to where i
wanted to go
the main star this whole thing is the
re-engine
that engine is amazing and i only played
the demo to check out the engine to see
okay the raid tracer which is a little
wonky on both consoles or whatever they
don't really know how to implement it
yet
because this is a cross-gen title this
title is made to play on your original
og
playstation 4 and the original og xbox
when they cut those titles those
consoles off and they just worrying
about these consoles
i think this re-engine is going to be
a real star going forward because it is
they're able to show
foliage they're able to show indoor
outdoor right they
the viometric fog um the mood
setting right it sets the mood better
than any engine that i've seen so far
i haven't seen the unreal engine five
but this engine is really good going
forward and i just like what they're
doing
i will say that resident evil is one of
the better games
that's a first person aspect like these
new resident evils that they
they do tell a story in a really good
way yeah yeah yeah i will give them that
let me let me ask you
because i'm sorry i guess so no right no
i was gonna say from uh
because y'all talk about the visuals and
stuff and obviously i i i could not
justify peter i got my backlog's crazy
but what i was gonna say is like how
because attic i know i spoke to you
briefly and i spoke to kaibab too it was
like different opinions so
visually is this game impressive that's
number one
and then two have y'all done the ray
tracing with the 45 because that's my
only downloading
performance i want to know like and have
you seen the differences what's your
opinions on i don't
so when i put ray tracing on um i did
with it with
and without right okay uh so ray tracing
with radiation off
it runs smoother it's it's at that 60
clip right right
and with the ray tracing has that weird
45 but to me
it still feels smooth and it's a it
feels like essentially a 30 right right
it's the way i see it um with the with
the improved lighting but like king said
it's still 100 wonky and because the
game is made to be across multiple
console generations
it just feels like the moments where it
should really shine where you look into
something
like you don't see it like i don't know
if this is by design but
when you look going to a bathroom with
something where you should have
reflective mirrors
nothing there that's why oh is that why
i didn't see them yeah yeah
ray tracing on yes yeah i have it on too
and i didn't see my person so
um yeah there's there's still some
weirdness with it i'm sure that that's
good
they're going to go away it would it
would know
it would break down all right you expect
ray tracing
and this is full ray tracing right you
would expect it like
when you went miles morales bathroom you
saw him right
when you do little things like that and
you saw him
i think as as heavy as this game is
you know with all the textures and
everything else
if you would have fully implemented ray
trace and i think this is a partial ray
tracing on certain things
if you fully implement it i think it
would bog it down
to underneath when they put the crazy
five right because you think about ray
trace shadows
and then have racist reflections right
someone just said like a really
interesting thing i never thought of
they said they don't want you to see
ethan's face
no that and that's another thing ethan
yeah ethan
that is sort of the every man thing
right it's just a very weird thing when
you go into
usually when they do that usually when
they project you onto someone besides
like someone like master chief
right they they don't even really let
you see hear their voice like
right like usually it's a silent pro
protagonist like
that is kind of interesting that ethan
because ethan's got a family
right he is a character as dry as he is
he's a character so it kind of makes me
think there is
there might be a reason that i don't
want you see his face
the game still looks great it does and
the i think what it does so well and
what resident
always does well is the atmosphere right
right it creates that sort of foreboding
atmosphere
when you it's almost like it's almost
like
it's like a walking similar especially
in first person it feels more like a
walking simulator
but with action in it right because res
evil you pick up everything
that you see in the environment um you
know that you can find little secret
stuff
if it's kind of like shining and you
have to look for the shining of those
stuff yeah
so it does all of those old residual
things very well in terms of the
atmosphere and i
and i feel it and for me i like
werewolves um
i've always sort of been not now but
when i was younger like that movie the
howling
yeah these werewolves remind me of those
where it's like
these werewolves always seem like
they're in the middle of their
transformation
right and and you see like in a movie
you see the werewolf in the middle of a
transformation that's horrifying
like they're in pain they're screaming
they're yelling and it feels like these
werewolves are always
in that middle ground and that makes
them scary because they're still very
human-like
but in they're in this transformation
phase hold on what's that
your bro isn't here he said it's better
with ray tracing and
for uh fps is unlocked so it's between
45 and 60.
you said his beef in resident evil
engine is first person fps games is the
plastic look
and feel that wasn't in resident evil 2
and 3.
yeah well that that when you look at the
game right
it's weird it doesn't i'm not gonna say
it looks like re like reverse where it's
like this
this outline that the game has to it
right it's not that
but it does even when you go into the
most horrible looking place right where
the
the food is nasty and rotten and
whatever it looks
perfect right the only times you see it
differently is when you see
like you see that something was just
recently being cooked and you can still
see it like bubbling or something like
that but beyond that
it looks like a set piece otherwise like
you can't really manipulate it too much
too much um so it does have like a sheen
to it that i know what he's talking
about
and when you think about how nasty the
place is that you're in
it takes you out of it a little bit but
i still think the overall atmosphere
does what it's supposed to do no doubt i
haven't gotten past that really
um but we'll we'll see because some
people are like this is the greatest
ever
yeah some people are like it doesn't
completely anybody
last question anybody see lady d yeah i
haven't
no i haven't okay
i don't care what nobody say that was
the setup for me when i saw all three of
them i was like
oh
[Laughter]
you know what the wildest thing was when
she walked in the room because i didn't
know how tall she was right i just heard
everybody say this right so like
i saw somebody on the street and she
walked him she ducked in the room i said
good god
did
uh cosplaying as her yes oh man oh yeah
i can't wait to get to these shows
time time all right
we got dt taylor with the five dollar
super chat when you finish the game
everything becomes clear okay so we have
something to look for damn you finished
the game good god
it's only long eight to ten hours if
somebody did tag me it was like
oh is this considered dlc because it's
eight to ten hours wow
i said miles morales is only three hours
[Laughter]
and eight to ten hours i'm okay with
that
yeah jason's like i'm good i'm tired of
all these hundred hour games coming back
together
yeah i'm okay if it's a long long game
if
there's substance there if it has to be
a winter three caliber
yeah if they literally just have like 20
percent has substance a really good game
but and then like 50 it's just like it's
just there
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my cat is stuck
in a tree could you please
help me yeah i love ac these guys know i
love ac but valhalla is just beating me
down
hold on let's go
ruin you how how many hours do you have
i have without barely doing anything i
have about 80 hours
jesus oh go okay
and i have 150 plus in odyssey
jesus odyssey's shorter
i finished with 132 hours
the original assassin's creed games are
12 to 15 hours which i think is
is probably the good spot perfect and
origins is probably as far as i would go
time time-wise i'm telling you right now
the story
alone is 50 hours yeah so if you ain't
did the story
oh yeah yo that's the thing when they
when somebody tells you beeline the
story nah
have you been going to the table and
going to the different places
the different places just trust me when
i tell you you're going to be like ah
finally done right and then you will go
to the table and there's going to be 12
more
[Laughter]
i'm warning you just just out of
curiosity
just out of curiosity chase do you
prefer the older assassin's creeds or
the newer assassin's creeds
and here's the thing though from a
gameplay standpoint i loved
origins when they redid some of the
stuff i just wanted them to combine
that with the old style because at this
point it's not really assassin's creed
one of the the the worst things you
could do is be stealthy what's the
what's for what i could just go in here
and kill 90 guys
and go right to lunch on games you gotta
sneak you get overwhelmed
and you actually like you had one hit
assassination yeah
when somebody cut his throat and you out
like right i felt like the the cells
weren't where they wanted to be and they
wanted to evolve it
but at the same time they're like we
need to change the game play up and then
you probably had like half the
development there's only one
left from the original games yeah yeah
wow they probably had people in the the
team was like
this is not even assassin's creed let's
just rename it
but but people gonna buy that though
like that but see this is it turned into
gains of a service and stuff like that
they had to monetize things they had to
make money
and they figured with origin and i
thought origins was just
when i first saw it they brought me back
in because i had stopped
community as much as i i
i don't dislike the newer ones i think
they're cool but
i prefer the older one where it felt
like they were building towards an
overall narrative yes
yeah every game but now it just feels
like yo you going to greece
yeah it feels like there's nothing
that's combining them anymore they're
just
random games like sovereign said i like
that
assassination aspect of it right like
you really had to go assassinate this
person
and it really meant something to me
you're going to love
the book of jt shout out to he got an
article
that he made oh no i gotta salute the
whole team
yo we posted in a couple of forums and
he was just like has assassin's creed
lost his way
because he's like it's not that it's a
wack game he said it's just not
different it's not assassin's creed it's
not the game that the whole thing was
predicated on stealth and
and remember moving between the crowd
you know what i'm saying
i would really like like one of these
writers that you know jason schreier or
someone
so like go out and find out what
happened to this
happening franchise [ __ ] i i feel like i
feel like it was one of those things
where maybe assassin's creed was on the
chopping block
and they were about to just stop it was
like yo let's
let's just let's just turn i have a
feeling differently i have a feeling
valhalla is the last of this type of
game for a while
and it's going to be a little different
whatever i don't think that is
they're making way too much money this
is the most profitable game i guess
because it's the store that it's not the
it's not the copies it's the store
you there's more stuff available for
purchase
yep stuff that you can earn and keep in
mind
that's the most [ __ ] game i have
every
piece of armor i got every every
collectible i did everything on the
entire map
and i still can't get anything in that
store
listen what are you telling you is true
because when i was playing
millions i would i
literally i probably spent like 300 in
that game oh you actually spent money
no no no no chase no lie i've
purchased it's people like yeah that's
the issue chase
when you purchase gear sets right um
it's not at your level like you still
have to level up this stuff with
materials in the world right so whatever
you purchase it is at that but you still
have to level this stuff up
so if you got something it's not the
hottest greatest
because when you go up four or five
levels there's something else in the
store like the uh
pergamos uh uh armor or whatever that
comes with the new horse
that comes with the hoop the gear for
the girl and the guy and it comes with
the sword the bowl
and some something else you're like oh i
need that and then you get that
and then there's something else in the
store and you know what what's bad i
know we have to move on but yeah like
when it comes to sassafras i thought
syndicate was good
and it's great i thought it was a great
game but at the end of the day like
maybe they had to do this like maybe the
cells aren't going to kill me i got that
the change you know it's funny you guys
[ __ ]
and king you guys know marlon and marlon
is he has been behind like
generations behind right so he's just
now
playing these and he's blazing out yeah
and
he like he got to see that he played one
he was like
that's that's all right i said play two
mm-hmm yeah
he played two and he was like oh my god
he played every like
i and i'm like i wish i could erase my
memories
to play them again and have that feeling
right now yeah
it is crazy facts we got what we got two
was so good that they made like four
other games
yeah exactly no we got we got the wise
old gamer
upgrading to lord gold thank you so much
for watching
then we got [ __ ] j five dollars
i can't shoot the werewolves they're all
doing matrix moves yeah the werewolves
are doing those moves
yeah i see them do the [ __ ] i thought it
was me no
it's like it's like a quick like a
sidestep tricks type site
you have to like wait for them to come
to a complete stop stop and then shoot
them in the head yeah
bob i just like when they do that matrix
move i just walk up with that just start
knifing them
then we got lord roughness with the five
pound super chat resident evil 8 demo
was good but i pre-ordered mass effect
legendary edition and can't wait for
launch
i'll get rea when it comes to game pass
what else then we got mr bad bit with
the five dollar super chat
homie hello everyone uh i i gtd spent
some time with my mom but iop
crew y'all have been absolutely crushing
it love seeing everyone growing to new
heights
thank you my brother he had a great
interview with greg miller with greg
miller yeah absolutely
sure this is a podcast i'll get get the
playstation podcast mixed up but
follow mr bad bit man you gotta show the
playstation podcast going on what else
we got
we're good all right cool let's get this
joined out this will be quick
fps boost man it's on the scene shout
out the major nelson the team
that um yeah xbox released their largest
drop of games featuring fbs boot to date
bringing the total number boosted games
from 23 to 97.
many of these are included in game pass
game pass ultimate ea
play games included and i think out of
um all those games
41 of them are games with up to 120
frames per
second so shout out again lord jason
around the team we've had a man around
multiple times out here doing the lord's
work with these frame rates
so i want to bring to the realm you know
just how you guys feeling about
more fps boosted games start with a lord
chase buddy
you know you can never have too many fps
phrase is good man yeah that's that's it
for me i feel
fair enough fair enough lord attic 120
frames or just frames in general games
that ran at 30 maybe at 60 how you
feeling
no like it's a good thing i feel like
you know it's like i said you could use
it for multiple things for marketing
purposes for playing certain games that
you wouldn't normally get you know it's
like i said on the shot podcast last
night
you know when the next dragon age comes
out be like you can play inquisition for
60 frames on the xbox
uh it's good marketing purposes uh
and at the end of the day it doesn't
hurt anyone like like more options is
always good and like if we're benefiting
from it
then they need to do it more like salute
to delilah hd she got that
mug right now she got that lord's mother
i grow women gay i see y'all salute
delilah that's what's up
what else you got yeah that's pretty
much all though like look
it's a good thing i feel like they need
to continue to invest into it
uh yeah for some reason people feel like
you can only work on newer games and you
can't do old games at the same time
these are multi-billion trillion dollar
companies they can do both i can assure
you
and this one anyway yeah this is all
hardware level
this is not the the devs are just laying
back pain like yeah go ahead turn it on
go ahead
no doubt yeah particularly real quick
any particular game you went back to to
try the test yeah
uh i'm eventually because i never played
dragon age inquisition
uh i played the first one and then like
they're
like towards the like the middle of the
360 era i was like in and out of gaming
i wasn't gaming i was gaming and
and i a lot of games slipped through my
hands like
the the bio shock slipped through me
like
oh so a lot of those type of games
yeah so you know i i'm i'm i'm very
excited to play like dragon age
inquisition
yeah no doubt that's a very good
fps boost oh my god i'm loving this as a
that's all that's also how i i missed
out on mass effect
fair enough listen i i'm i'm loving this
give me more as a proud new owner of a
little man
little man off don't worry i got you the
little man's the xbox series
yeah i know i ain't dropping no kids
yeah i
yeah so i mean listen just to see all of
these games
the amount of games you said 44 total
at least at least seems like at least 40
of them
41 accounts right and let's say let's
say another
maybe another 10 maybe another 10 or
actually 120 as well on the s
yeah and to see all these games up to 60
on the s
you know people talking about the s
holding stuff back at this and other
sorry man i i know bro like this this
this is really really exciting to me
uh i actually on my ex at home i
downloaded mad max because i was like
mad max i i started it on console it's a
great game
such a lovely game man if you love
if you love uh arkham style combat this
is that
with murder like you you know what like
i like that but i like the car combat
like the car
fantastic i love that game i hope they
make a sequel to that i doubt it because
it's been a long time yes avalanche i
don't think it's gonna happen but
i played it i started on the xbox one
and then i got it on pc for like five
dollars and obviously it was running
like 60 on pc and i'm like
i'll just continue it on the console so
now i got it at 60 on the console
and i and i beat i mean i 100 of that
game and i'll just go in to see it again
just to see it running at 60.
i'm sorry i got it i was gonna say like
mad max gave me like kind of like
a game that ubisoft would make kind of
thing yeah that combat dog
combat no doubt no doubt lord king
about this fps boost oh oh oh
let me put it should i put a ball who
did that for us should i get it ready
shout out to the bed the greatest bed in
the business jason ronald and that team
um i told you dudes it was going to be
some crazy stuff that was going to drop
and i told you it was on monday dudes
like
how do you know the money shut up good
news drop it
they want you to permeate that
throughout the whole week they're gonna
wash over you
let that wash over you so i put on
recall
i forgot how beautiful recoil look um
because you you listen to because you
know chase asked me what game
it's a lot of games that i was ashamed
that i really like
that dudes is talking bad about yeah and
i put in recall the design on the
character is so
nuts and i remember going to that e3 and
seeing the trailer and being
uh uh wowed by it and couldn't wait to
get it and then when i did get it
it was one of the most uh twitch
trigger uh things like the dexterity
that you needed to have to play that
game was nuts yeah
and a lot of people gave up on the game
because of how hard it was
and and the stuff that you had to do
because y'all wasn't used to certain
gameplay
and not saying that uh it didn't fit for
everyone just like
fraternal doesn't fit for everyone right
i'm not saying that's a bad game yeah
it's just certain games just don't fit
for everyone right and i put in that
same space as return
i don't think return was gonna achieve
the great heights that it's supposed to
get
and somebody's going to probably say oh
king is equate and record return go play
recall shut up
um i put it on and i saw the 60 frames
per second
solid no dips i was like
damn okay you got pc yeah i got i got
this super high-powered
ridiculous pc over here that he never he
don't use that i'm not even gonna sit
here and fraud on you
i'm not i'm i'm a fraud i'm a fraud
why not well why why don't you use a pc
you play a lot of those games on there
but besides the fact that you guys point
out that uh pc dudes is um
whatchamacallit single player single
player i say this to say
cheaters i was back back with 3dfx right
and going buying these graphic cards and
doing all this crazy stuff
and doing all this ram um me and saul
went through the whole rigamarole of all
that stuff right there
they turn around compared to uh console
turnaround consoles we saved for eight
years we have
that 360 playstation 3 era good god i
loved it
like because we didn't have to upgrade
anything your pc got to get upgraded
every two years you don't
know man i i don't know
but that's something that that that's to
me that's false negative
yeah that's something that people will
say chase let me explain to you
and i know where you're going i had one
computer last year
he's gonna tell you this i could watch
it because i'm probably watching my room
you can't have the new hotness 30 90 out
here
and he don't have it see that's not king
so
it's like i gotta i gotta have the best
all the time
yeah so far it's gonna become this cycle
so he just said you know what i'm
getting out of this
i'm going back to where i like to be at
anyway and with the ecosystem he liked
to be at because
but when him and solve was in the game
it was
every year i know i know people that do
that yeah
so that's really what it was it's not
that you have chase
i really just can't justify seventeen
hundred dollars on the graphic card put
it this way chase whatever
when the new whip come out every year
and then plus right now with you know
mining in the way it's going on with the
graphic cards yeah inflating like crazy
like
like it looked kind of intimidating over
there in the pc right ain't gonna lie
like
like some will be like yo i'm gonna get
on this pc they've been doing it but
they've been keeping up with what's
going on and
then they finally go by the graphics
card whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
why is this so much yeah you know what i
mean
they're probably not going to go back
for a while and they're just going to
assume that's how much the cards cost
chase i was doing it you know like
upgrading and getting doom and stuff
like that
and you know like that remember when
doom came out you saw that trailer
when you were three came out i remember
yeah
i went out and spent three thousand
dollars yes sir
to play doom 3 and half-life 2. no yes
yes sir
i i under i understand so listen when
you got a new graph
right now and you can't play
crisis at 120 frames because i don't
think even
the new pcs can play prices
you are playing a battle that i just
can't win so yeah
okay okay i still have it that's right
overall
so the frame percent so i'm looking at
all my games
and then i'm looking at the list and i
put something in i was like damn
i love they're bringing
it forward just whatever you purchased
before
this is no cost to you facts you know
this is this is just
and it's it's fan service i don't care
what anybody say this is fan service
if you got a game and then you thought
it looked a certain way or you
remembered it a certain way
and you put it in and it's feeling how
you remember and it wasn't that
but it feeling how you remembered it
because our revisionist history changes
yeah but we see it and they just bring
it forward i just think it's a great
thing
it's no cost i just like the fact that
there's
no cost it's that it's that pc thing
when you get a new graphics card
and the first thing i always play on a
new graphics card is the last game that
gave me
any kind of trouble on the last one yeah
i just i just throw it at it and see if
we could just
and it's that same feeling on console
and like
yesterday on that mass effect show bill
still was talking about that idea of
like this is something nobody really
wants in the console space
you know people people were shooting it
down and now when you look at it it is
the crux of the xbox message
right it's the fight he had to fight for
that who wouldn't want it
during the climate on consoles see from
a pc perspective
yeah i get it but it's like from a
console perspective
at the time 2015 people were like
not me but i mean a lot of the
executives internally were like we're
not sure
if the gamer is really going to respond
to that and i told them when they
announced it
to this day and i said this on a joint
on the mass effect of a show to build
that's the biggest pop i've heard at an
xbox
conference low key in a long like when
they when people were like yo you could
play
all your 360 games and you know you know
majority of them and
all this stuff people were like oh my
god when it came out
it was just mass effect really well i
mean they had a few of the tests because
they were the technical
but before we from that era that like i
told bill
where you remember you bought your
genesis you had to have the old tech
in the new tech to play the old so you
had to have the power based converter to
play mass system
you had to have all these little
converters and things internally put in
and sometimes that raised the cost of
the console but they're doing this
through virtualization so
it was like it was like magic was like
how are they doing this oh this is crazy
that kind of thing so yeah to that point
it was pretty
amazing i'm gonna jump right quick if if
kane is finished real quick yeah i'm not
i'm absolutely friendly
40 games off the list yeah this is fire
you know what i'm saying like i don't
want to um understate it
because at the end of the day i love
them continuing to support it
and i am team 120 like if you got the
the means you know what i'm saying i got
that i got the cx lg cx
seeing these games at 120 really 120 is
crazy
oh man it really hits i was playing card
on 120. oh
pc with all the cheaters
and then i got on my ps5 and it was on
60 and i'm not as
like a pc snob because because pc is the
biggest headache i've ever
experienced consistently you and i and i
fouled you in the registry
codex nothing you don't do that on
console i talk about it all the time
but but that that that 60 is it's still
solid but i was just like it didn't it
didn't look as smooth
and like and i was like man i wish i'd
never seen a lot of stuff you wish you
didn't
ever see because it meant now it's that
mess you up because now you go back down
and yo
they got mad at me i'm uh he's a stop
now
i'm even worse than cog is now sitting
there like i tried to play dragon age
like sit like three or four months ago
before they did this update
and i played like maybe four hours i
gotta drop this card
it feels like you had molasses you all
slow no
so that joint right there um feels like
you have weights on you yeah it's like
you got ankle weights or
you run it with ankle weights so look at
the other day for me all i cared about
self sleep was my titan four
two bro like time four two that one
twenty i loved titanfall that was crazy
shout out to them
i don't know if you've seen soft they
got a huge uptick in player base i don't
know if it's directly related
yeah it's related to that and the apex
implementation and then baseball too is
like
back in online community for some reason
i mean i heard it when i i don't see a
scenario where vince sampela can't
yeah we get a title so that's that i
wanted you know 120 was crazy
i got one beef though xbox fans i need
y'all you stand up right now
i got one beef there's one game that's
not on this list that we know damn it
should be on this list where is that
rise southern rome y'all
yeah i love that game i love me
surprised
that was one of the underrated games in
the chat somebody put it
in there i got to the awesome i was like
where's ross
i feel like there was one thing that if
microsoft could have done really put in
a lot of
hype with people if they could have
secretly bought that
ip during the beginning like the middle
of last gen
and then when the series x was announced
uh like the sequel was a launch time
i don't know what it just has to take
over and just fight
you see that you're good
i don't think i don't think uh i don't
think they're they're apart
you ain't gonna chase you are not sorry
real quick at it you are not going to do
what you did you put 100
in that chat put eyeballs so you
understand
the fact that you know hey let me go
over there just purchase this
[ __ ] they have to want to be thank you
chase i don't
like no this is what would have happened
like like you know we enable that super
chat feature right
so if chase went to do that and that was
not that that's just saying we ain't
being bought
but see this is this is this is it if
there ain't no super chat features i
can't buy a company
this world is built off of this right
listen
they don't want to be bought you got
something i want and i'm trying to make
it happen and i'm talking to you nicely
you don't want to do it i'm just going
to buy your
[Music]
you don't capitulate
right but people people don't understand
that like when you have a company
that in different departments that
there's a budget that is allocated
some people think that sony or
playstation has
access to sony's entire budget exactly
like that's not how it works where they
just have all the money from the cup and
they can just throw it
right oh you can't do that right but
let's just say satya just said
you know what i really need this all it
takes is one dude that doesn't have
access to the budget that should like
rise
right right you like fries and he looked
and said yo how come ryze ain't on the
list
oh because um they didn't they didn't
okay who what
they didn't okay like yeah not even okay
okay so did you talk to him about the
bread or the situation
no how much they cost like what did you
buy the building
what they worth oh they work for that uh
13 billion
all right
it's not lose burning me down
you can't buy shares for a company
that's not published
like listen chase you know and this is
everybody here
if it's something that you want you have
the your pockets is flush
right right let's just say you paid all
your bills your pockets is flush
you go to the store and you see
something that you really want something
that you care about that you really
wanted
and you know it's overpriced and you may
not get the value back later on but
do you care at that moment are you gonna
walk out the store with what you want
are we comparing are we
are we comparing like a macy's trip
that's a macy's trip though facts
sometimes you gotta dangle them off the
roof
business moving on that's all i got
shout out to the team and all the fps
boost games good to see
see them all moving and shaking out here
um we want to get some chat and then
final topic let's get a body at this
point yeah this is three twenty four
while i promise
we got the wise old gamer with the 5
super chat
yeah re8 making me scream like a little
girl and those werewolves are acting
like harvey weinstein
oh my god wow
[Laughter]
then we have mods gaming with the 10 10
plm i just say ten dollars ten dollars
in the chat
uh first mass effect is the best i don't
know
he's trolling hard hard he love him he
loves star trek
though maybe he maybe he actually
believes in that no no he lost his team
he won he all got that last video was
lit yeah shout out to mods man that's
the homie
then we have lord roughness the five
pound super chat
fps boost is the goat went back today
playing deus ex mankind divided
yeah fantastic game play is beautiful
who did that for me
really we got king one supreme two
dollar super chat steam said the average
gpu is a 1060 that's
this is true pc master racer front
how would they know that i guess
by um like the base level whatever they
they copied and stuff like that yeah
they have they
they have all that like you know you can
do the metrics on the settings to see
the average out
because what i'm running what what i'm
running sovereign 210 ti's on my joint
right now
yeah two two three yeah that's a lot
which is
for no reason yeah and i'm just sitting
here with that face you know that face
that jordan plays
using it you're using that for like
tress effect
you you're not even optical for no
reason like you literally have
a graphics card that's not peeking
yeah they're just sitting there just
watching the other graphics called
working hardware surveys oh they said
the survey
but like how many people filled out
people
i guess a lot they haven't they probably
do if they're giving you a free game i
fill it out yesterday
i don't think they're giving out free
games i've never seen this survey yeah
it's we got one away dragons tv five
dollars shout out to
120 fps yeah yeah hip-hop on yesterday
yeah big shout out
we got shout out to the 120 fps being
called the cheater more than ever now
in a multiplayer i'm a multiplayer god
now
let the bodies hit the floor facts no
doubt
and we got raiden blade five pound super
chat hey i'm still at work but there's
no way i was missing it again
glad to be among the lords thank you for
joining us
know that we all caught up
we have malik tyler right yeah malik
malik tyler two dollars should we chat
phil
i like you and i wants you to stop
yoga you see you see this nonsense king
that you'd be pretty good
king where my pyro is up to a level
whatever i don't know
i'll join you sometimes because i'll run
you through the stuff if you see me on
y'all guys see me on king david otw on
xbox you see me on just join me i don't
care
what's up then we have raiden blade once
again two pound super chat hunting that
akari
finest yeah you need that kari vest i
can get you a car rebuild but you gotta
let me know what you're trying to do
no doubt no doubt then we got the homie
bontes five dollars oh
the lords of the realm quality sunday
content here thank you oh all that stuff
that's the cheetah i don't even see the
cheetah that's the tree the last word
podcasting to be the best damn destiny
podcast okay what he said
shout out to evan that's my hope yeah we
gonna be extra it's not the last word
we're gonna be extra about
exactly that salute to him man i thought
we had a fun show we're quaking us
on friday we all go and yeah we're
caught up we're gonna cool let's get it
oh
never mind with the two dollar super
mass effect to the ghost salute thank
you i'll scratch that i'm gonna send you
your money back brad thank you
you can't take your opinion i mean at
that point you've already read it
anyway moving on let's get this last j
and then we're out of here
he could not wait to talk about this um
so it looks like yeah the
news has come out ps5 redesign will
enter production 2020 2022.
so uh yeah sony will probably start
production on a playstation 5 hallway
redesign this is according to
uh tiny's taiwanese uh business website
digi ties and they said they plan to
start producing the redesigned ps5
console between the second and third
quarters of next year
and apparently they say the uh redesign
will come with a new
semi customized six nanometer cpu
from amd and yeah this is king
definitely want to talk about this
so um yeah king what's your thoughts on
this whole situation
what have you told us that unstable
monstrosity of
an old box you needed help
i told you that juggling stuff like oh
we should use
cpu or should we use gpu
with the ssd expansion it's too hot it's
too hot to
turn it off that that that kick in
fairness
there's no fairness here
no listen i told you dudes they had to
fix it
and from the moment they made it they
came out they was like yo
they got it they're loving it they said
but you know the problems with it
don't worry about that
yo maternal is crashing every other
second
and
they told us we can't have the cpu and
the gpu movement at the same time
we did it and this is what happened
so that's the result of doing two are
you implying that that is the result of
them doing too much
they said we tried we put it at 1080p
this thing can't do it
this is what happens when you do too
much with too little
it breaks and now we gotta fix it
now they gotta go back to the box and
they gotta fix it and i'm telling you
right now
they already got a redesign they already
got it
they just put it through its basis and
they don't want to bring it out tomorrow
because they don't want
dudes like me who purchase to be upset
and riot
so what they're doing is they're gonna
give us a six months look out so we
gonna be like oh this is normally what
they do see what cog wanted to tell you
this is gonna be normal normally what
they do one year
you don't come out six months ago and
talk about the new stuff
we don't do that talk about what's
happening now where's my ssd slot
anyway oh no chase
five redesign your thoughts sir
on this topic ps5 design is trash
oh i thought i mean i said that when i
when i seen the console oh i don't know
this is very ugly
oh okay well you can keep it keep in
mind
the ps4 pro was the worst console i ever
purchased oh wow
this so we're clear it is so loud i'm
sure y'all heard it
call of duty uh i mean 666 gigs of
usable storage
when you know you you advertise
one terabyte hard drive that's not it i
haven't had
um very many problems but i i'm already
known when you get like new tech like
that
especially from i don't trust game
companies like that anyway
i'm already known i'm gonna get that
three-year warranty
right off rip cause i know that
somebody's gonna do something and i'm
gonna have to get a replacement
and even the controller i've already i'm
on my third
i played tons of games and you know and
i'm gonna be honest i think it was what
call of duty is probably the main
culprit what's all the triggers
now what the triggers it was the it was
the controller drift on the analogs
really yeah
i noticed it like the controller i
didn't use for um call of duty has been
fine
but you know with the games where you
use that a lot you push it in
it's just a gg wow i don't really
i don't i'm not really i don't really
like the analog chase talking to his
people
they were like why did you buy three ps5
controllers well i mean i
he said chase what you doing with these
things i mean i
i bought two off right but i had to buy
two replacements and i play a lot of
games like yeah
you play games a lot you know you might
i have a problem you know i might
you break something you feel good when
you do it but then you like either now i
gotta clean this up or not i have to
replace this
to the dual says there have been some
rage what
mobitz yeah now but this controller that
controller drift is real though there's
a reason
there's a reason that there's a reason
why it led you to that overheating and
all that i ain't seen it you know what
i'm saying i don't really focus on that
because we already know
like when you release new stuff
somebody's gonna get the short end of
the stick
yeah you know but this controller drift
is not in it
and you know what it's funny well we're
going looking at him
and he's we're going to leak the
controller drift because if the
controller wasn't drifting
chase won't be doing none of this
when my nephew come over he wanna play
me i'll bust his head i give him the
butt controller
i know you fine we used to do that was
funny
it was it was one of the kids challenges
i'll never forget he got killed
and he no i don't it was an elite
controller
so it wasn't it wasn't oh yeah and he
started slamming it on the desk in front
of him and you see the buttons flying
off
i've seen the gifts
let's move this down the line lord
addict babe the ps5 readers out are you
surprised this is not a big deal to you
and yet
i mean have we not uh king did did you
start gaming this generation
did we not have an xbox one and xbox one
s well
do we not have like three variations of
that this is not really
this is this is not that this is a
redesign we have
every generation right but this is
what they're saying is that as a result
of chip
shortages they're they're all they're
changing
the innards right right and that's where
they lose me because i'm just like
this is a bespoke piece of hardware that
you took
multiple years to create an r d and all
of a sudden you're gonna
swap something out and throw something
else in there
again i never made a console in my life
i never will but
i don't know how this works but it just
feels like yeah we're going to swap this
out
and put something else in that we can
actually find
i don't know look someone dude someone
in the chat said
someone said the chat said attic not
after one year come on be real
we just saw leaks but we just saw leaks
it's not like they've announced this
like they don't announce it and remember
the the redesign is so is only internal
as well yeah it's only internal it's
only internal
um yeah yeah cause if i have to defend
places
you saw the dude break it down and he
put it on the table
the whole oh my god kevin parks right
that is kind of that that is interest
like evan's dead
like literally is simple on xbox but
we're not gonna act like they don't
redesign these
literally after they finish the ps5 the
first thing they did is like how do we
make this show
smaller like they want to make them
smaller because they want to make more
money off them
and they want to update stuff so they
can because though
100 of you if you can quickly figure out
a way to make the exact same machine
cheaper you're going to do it right
it just feels that with what people have
been saying you're probably on this
just no no i'm just saying i'm just
saying
it's a nice way to cook the fraud alert
but listen to what i'm saying no this is
a nice way to cover it up
if they do have issues and they're like
well we can't find this
and while we're in there we can go ahead
and make a few little adjustments
y'all really doing this y'all right i'm
gonna say this
same energy because if this was
microsoft
after six months i would say the same
thing and
nah these twitters these twitter streams
them sony dude twitter
this is the playstation player's face i
told you
so i know for a fact y'all gonna get
this work i don't care what you're
saying
this is a different machine that's
unstable you got a heat sink
yo right here where's the he white
five issues though well it's just the
shortages and right now
heavy freaking yeah but the way he
pitches it's like yo everybody
my god exactly i don't see it
there
during that they said that a possible
you know redesign would have to happen
now from my understanding it's purely
component focused it's not any
significant external changes
and if the wafer chip is just with the
six nanometers and to get the yields the
same
it's no big deal but the thing is the
ps4
that the wafer was the problem before
and with the yields on that before
i don't know what they say they
dismissed that you don't remember before
they were saying they was having bad
yields
and that's why they wasn't producing as
much as they was i remember
that was the bloomberg oh i remember
something like that and they tried to
rebuff that was like nah
i would yield i think right i think
i think if it i think if anything that
they they might have went to the drawing
board a little early because of the
shortage
it's like look we're going to redesign
it anyway right so let's try to get this
out
within a year and a half to two that way
we can cost and
you know because clearly it's not coming
out this year right but like whatever
so so i mean and they're not going to
launch it in the middle of next year
most likely be like holiday of next year
but
it's not even going to be but
they do hike these up oh they're getting
like
everything but the serial number is
going to be exactly it's going to be the
real number the stealth joint but what
i'm trying to say is this is not
this is not present like this has
happened before the ps4 had a revision
generator that's like everything
i got that one yeah okay gotcha oh
10 months in yeah 10 months in they had
a revision just like this was the chip
change on the internal
nothing major no it's switched on it
yeah the switch is done
like that but that don't work to my
narrative though
i'm with king today
you know what it is it's just funny to
me that
we haven't heard xbox say the same thing
like no no i mean that's because it has
an elite codex
we look what we call it looking at the
quantity
see this is it's more funny
like all y'all talking this level-headed
stuff i'm not trying to be level here
i'm not trying to do that what i'm
trying to do is bring the jokes
so the joke's here yo the joke really is
it's and it's sad though the joke is on
us all those playstation dudes that was
there from day one and a cop
out with joint that was running out
there that's happy because i saw one
dude on my timeline
and he didn't like the way that i was
trashing places that he was right yeah
yeah i was going in on that
man he's blocking used to follow me yeah
he used to follow me no he didn't block
me
but he just unsubbed me and and i
laughed i said don't come at me this
skin i'm gonna break your heart
so don't do that because i'm gonna
really tear you up pause
so um he just got his playstation
so i i'm like oh okay i thought you was
a fan um
he didn't like that part that's what he
that's when he blocked it
because i said you know i was out there
day one i got mine right
he tried to give me some excuse i don't
care about it
but i mean we can't act like these are
like you just walk into a game stop in
bible and kill
oh no but i laid out in front of the
front in the store i was about to fight
it dude
but at the same time i tell you this
it's
he just got it and i understand yeah
from the aspect
and i'm keeping the same energy i just
got mine i don't want to hear
your redesign right when you ain't even
talking about
what's designed in the box already all
right so
why we let switch go away with not doing
that expansion report we had all these
wonderful ideas with the expansion
report what's going on
and that's not key to the ssd as far as
memory goes
there's an ssd expansion port that's in
there
and like chase said they said one
terabyte but he only got 600 and some
odd uh
gigs of ram why are we not
more on their heads cause with this ssd
and they're talking about redesigns i
don't care how my new it is
i don't care if they're changing the
fins on the side let's talk about what's
really going on with this box because
if maternal people is telling you that
it's the hardware issue
how many signs do we need to get to
understand that something's up with this
box and they're not
really being clear at all right okay oh
yeah i just feel like yeah
i just don't know no i just worried
about the fact again
you took how many years to build this
machine it's not like
a pc part where pc part is more sort of
kind of across the board right it is a
short all right there is a shortage
y'all know a hundred percent weirdo
and let's not act like both these
systems they come in hot
i don't know 100 i just worry about a
specific piece that was crafted
specifically for that machine
right being replaced right and nothing
else being changed
question yeah what's up y'all y'all
think this is gonna be something coming
up next next holiday
i don't know i think it's a stealth
thing we'll get it we'll probably get it
by the end of the year
in the newest model surprise if it's if
it's next if it comes out this year then
sure if it comes out next year i just
feel like
that's what that'd be that'd be tough
that'd be two years right quick because
he brought
he said only playstation 4 slim got the
soc shrink
three years in three years okay okay i i
think
i don't think it's going to be like a
crazy redesign like you know how like
with the slim
i think you're really just going to see
something done on the back end
that they change something minor inside
the console itself
they're not going to tell anyone the
only reason we know is because we have
our ear to the ground
yeah and then
i will say this like this there's
something there's a scenario that's real
here and the fact is
as excited as people are still trying to
trying to find ps5s right
the demand is far outweighing uh what
what's
out there they don't they want to put as
many consoles as they
possibly can on shelves before xbox
really gets any momentum
when when the people who can't find the
console right oh specifically the
playstation 5 get fed up of not being
able to find a playstation 5
and and they do start to make that
determination of i'm just going to go to
the other side
right yeah you don't want to wait yeah
you can't wait that long
i don't care how excited people are for
your console people will get pissed off
they'll stop waiting yes but especially
the competition is delivering so i agree
let's get up out of here super chat poll
and then
okie dokie hold on a second
we got
okay raiden blade five pound super chat
is it true epic offered sony 200 million
to put their games on the epic store
i i believe that is there's there's some
talks about
what was happening with that all i know
is that they wanted their money to
to do cross play that's that's for sure
there's somebody
then we got jacob j five dollars on the
chat ps5 is a system made with
shoestrings and bubblegum
super chat that ps5 four and three
designs are all ugly
if she come from a broken home you can't
fix these analogies
eagles fan 76 two dollar super chat are
they going to fix
m2 cooling issue on the ps5 version
uh two i believe so i believe
i believe that's the real redesign i
believe the real redesign is them
fixing that coolant issue of the console
there we go eyes finally gave out uh
corey b
five dollars super jack king wants sony
to fail so bad
sega refugees stand up i'm not gonna lie
i just want their games i'm not gonna
sit here live
this is a stick up
tony bryant five dollar super chat they
still haven't enabled that ssd bay for a
reason that thing will go
nuclear yeah you would really hear that
fan
and then we uh we got mount money
you want to picture my ears rather get a
picture of my thumb so you can fix your
damn controller
[Music]
it's a redesign it's a fix it's an
admission that the playstation 5 and his
tools
are too close to the series s's
performance and competing with the
series x
i'll tell you this i will laugh i will
laugh
my [ __ ] if that that machine
comes in it comes in clocking in higher
for whatever reason it's like oh my god
that would be funny i'll be funny all
right yeah we're coming all right so the
new poll is up right now lords of
gaming.net check it out y'all
so um with the release of resident evil
village and now race tracing modes
featured on next generation consoles do
you have a problem
with ray tracing enabled if that mode
can't hit 60 fps
choices are a yes frame should not be
sacrificed for resolution or ray tracing
b no as long as there's an option or
perform for performance mode to hit 60
frames
or c i don't care i'm all about every
mode lady d
is in so that is
the legendary rocked out for damn near
three hours
push them to the limit love it lord
chase
money where can the five people find you
what you got going on sir
i ain't got nothing going on man check
the channel off man that's it
what's the date uh because you got to
exchange money too
you'll know when you get
[Laughter]
brother we love what you're doing out
here tons of fun bro we could have
talked
gaming in the sports and the competitive
scenes yeah for hours you out here
killing it love your energy and i got to
shout you out because what day i respect
about you
is you're never too hollywood you're
never too cool you know what i'm saying
like bigger than
you you're big out here bro you know
what i'm saying and to see you
still interact with the community and
not you know because we we've
experienced it when we were to come
really
oh yeah oh yeah we've experienced one of
them
they leave your message they act like
they ain't see it
you know what's that kind of thing i
never do that man
playing the subscriber count games and
all of that but respect to you you've
always been putting people on you've
been doing your thing
and uh it's a pleasure man keep
continuing to do you do your growth and
like appreciate it back in the realm bro
so sir yes sir
shakes money lord addict who made it
happen
my man you know what i'm saying waking
up on people find you what you got going
on
you can find me on twitter lord addict
iop follow me on youtube at gamingx
uh definitely i'm going to be doing
another return on stream tomorrow
i want to thank uh chase for coming on
man but i've been watching your content
for a little bit man it's nice to
actually do a podcast with you
thank you thank you i remember one time
i was gonna go on weaponworld you was on
it it was a long time ago
but 2015. man i ain't been over here
since
i remember i remember i missed that one
i was like man chase was on there
yeah you know it was it's it's it was
nice to have a podcast with me i
you know i don't know nothing about the
2k stuff the mad and stuff you know
that's a little bit
a little bit over my head but you know i
got you i always appreciate that even
stuff i don't care about you always make
it at least entertaining
thanks man no lord solve great debate
yesterday sir we're gonna find you to
find you yes sir yes so that was
fantastic uh you know you could sign me
lord top iop on twitter
be x sovereign at psn xbox live we'll
try to get some more this
mlb to show smoke um do that
play some res evil um get my little man
at some point this is
[Laughter]
this yeah a big shout out to chase i
think chase you put it perfectly
uh earlier when you said that it's
basically
people are afraid to laugh at themselves
on youtube and you're not afraid to do
that and if we
we all could be there and get to that
point where it's just
it's just jokes it's just fun facts uh
i think we'd all be in a better place so
i appreciate you and what you do man
no doubt lord king with all the smoke
and slander
today people find you
what do you have going on sir first of
all this is my first time meeting chase
oh and addict was talking about him all
week long right and
um i'm like okay so you know i get there
whatever and um you know i come in with
my music or whatever and she's like okay
what the hell is this
but i'm gonna tell you this first i love
somebody who's not thin skinned
second i love somebody who don't take
themselves too seriously when you talk
first the the hundred dollar superchat
that was like shut up king
no no no first and you did a stealth and
it was lit all right so first i love
that right
okay not not 100 just just
out of the box right that i love that
was real no when you told me with the
spider man
guys
i don't know if you want me to put them
out there like this i might not clip
that one
um
[Applause]
i love that i love that sequence
that's why when you heard me when i say
party city right yeah i went to parties
i got little costumes that sometimes i
put on and i do goofy things
if if you can laugh at yourself and
you're not afraid
to show the world you you will always be
successful
facts because we are all the same
but you got to be able to laugh you got
to be able to get that out and you bring
humor to your stuff you you rocked out
for three and a half hours with us and i
really appreciate that's a there's a few
that can rock out that whole half hours
and be engaging
you are engaging from the moment yeah
he's straight entertaining
i love you appreciate it even your cat
was like what's going on
yeah yeah yeah and and i get a little
bit messy that's me getting messy on the
side
we are not an xbox podcast guys
yeah i'm team one thousand xbox but also
i love playstation shout out the games
here for the sauce i see you put
all their covering through definitely
stop getting before they come we gotta
get them done
we got a mass erect two
xbox's omni man ps5 is invincible
then we got gaming forte sorry i missed
the show but hey
king boo-boo
[Laughter]
anyway so look we got tremendous show
had a lot of fun big another big week
next week man check it out it's going to
be super lit
another we don't go give it away but
another fun one in the realm
yo everybody sunday happy mother's day
in all that we will catch y'all next
[Music]
week
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you